So, da bin ich wieder.
Es ging schnell, hä?
Aufgegangen,
was gefuttert und gleich wieder
ongegangen.
Ongegangen, schein das Wort.
Online gekommen.
Mal gucken,
ob die Leute das überhaupt
auf dem Schirm haben,
dass ich wieder da bin.
wie man mich kennt sage ich das ja in der regel nur und kommt dann gar nicht
mehr an am sonntag aber diesmal bin ich am start
und richtiges pfeifferzeug extra raspberry pi rausgekramt dass wir es auf
der echten kiste machen können
Ja, habe ich doch gesagt, wir machen jetzt PXE-Bootstells.
Welcher in 50 Billiarden? Moin!
Schon moin dran gedacht.
Ich habe mich gefragt, wo ist er denn?
Da ist er.
Exzellent.
Ja, ich habe schnell gefuttert, ne?
Das stimmt.
Ich sage das immer, dann komme ich nicht auf.
Das ist korrekt.
Ich mach schon mal die VM an.
Dann erklär ich noch mal kurz, was wir jetzt eigentlich machen.
Massive Five Headstells.
Ich hab schon ein bisschen vorgearbeitet die letzten Tage.
Also ein bisschen Ahnung hab ich schon.
Aber wir müssen das mal alles zusammenbringen heute.
Max, ich habe eine Perle gefunden, die gerne in FFM chillt.
Goethestraße, Louis Vuitton Store,
zahl die Kollektion bar, fick auf Sponsor.
Aber du meinst jetzt wahrscheinlich eher sowas zum Essen.
Ja, also, okay, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
nichts Elegantes
zum lange
Essen gehen. Aber eine Sache,
die ich finde, die preis-leistungsmäßig gut ist
und wirklich extrem gut schmeckt,
ist
Shiking.
zu der nähe vom hauptbahnhof korean fried chicken das schmeckt mega nice nicht offenbach city hier
das brauche elbe elbe straße das schmeckt richtig nah ist scheiß auf pommes frites würde ich nicht
machen den da jungen jungen chicken und reis dabei beste weiß ich ob es auch speisekarten
gibt die alles mit pommes frites und kannst du komplett vergessen hier ist die speisekarte
genau hier jungen schicken jungen jungen jungen schicken mit mittagsmenü kostet das ganze auch
ich glaube 11 euro kostet mittlerweile 11 euro mittagsmenü jungen chicken da ist reis dabei
mittagsmenü ich nehme mir immer noch ein extra portion reis die städte bis noch eine alte
speisekarte steht überhaupt nicht drauf extra portion reis kost 150 nur ich war auch gestern
erst wieder da aber das ist das ist echt also es mir schmeckt das richtig gut und
mittagsmenü ist preislich auch in ordnung gestern samstag gab es kein
mittagsmenü gestern war ich da und habe hier gegessen für 14 50 genau für 14 50
zweimal extra reis dabei noch mal drei euro und was kleines zu trinken das
wertschrumpfen was gekostet aber unter der woche ist also kann ich empfehlen
wäre in der nähe vom hauptbahnhof was
neuestes für mittags sucht er cheeking
statt schicken tofu zu bekommen ganz
ehrlich bei einem korean fried chicken
restaurant ist ohne chicken vielleicht
bisschen unvorteilhaft oder es ist
wahrscheinlich der richtige lagen pxe
ja pxe wird mich abfacken heute ist
jetzt schon abfucken mega pay in the ass ist das so ich habe mir in den raspberry
pi moment habe das nicht chat aber das nicht heute morgen schon abgegradet bin
ich jetzt total hängen geblieben.
Wir haben das doch heute Morgen
schon abgekriegt. Gab es denn schon wieder was Neues?
Es geht aber schnell.
Arch, by the way.
Na gut.
Tja.
Die Soße und das Panierte und so,
das könnten sie auch mit Tofu machen, aber ich glaube,
das passt einfach zu Korean Fried Chicken nicht.
So, Upgrade.
so dann würde ich sagen fangen wir mal recht entspannt an wir installieren einfach mal auf
dem auf der micro sd karte ich habe hier eine 64 gig samsung pro micro sd karte endurance ja
nur vom feinsten für den chat installieren wir mal hier ein aktuelles raspberry pi image drauf
Passt das nicht? Och nee!
Ah doch passt. Sehr gut.
Connect zur VM. Raspberry Pi Imager.
Insufficient permissions. Na gut, dann halt als Sudo.
Select your Raspberry Pi Device. Alter, was ist das für einer? Keine Ahnung.
Moment, was ist denn das für einer?
kann man das von außen wenn es in dem gehäuse ist irgendwo erkennen dass er kennt man ja ja
das ist ein vierer ein vierer der hat 22 blaue usb anschlüsse das muss ein vierer sein das muss
ein vierer sein es ist auch neu dass man das auswählen muss raspberry pi os 64 spiel port
of the beyond rixi raspberry pi desktop nee ich will keinen raspberry pi desktop haben
kann man da irgendwie
No Desktop Environment.
Das will ich haben.
So.
Next.
Da drauf.
Enter your hostname.
PXE Champ.
Ähm.
Was?
Was wollen die von mir?
Berlin ja okay keyboard layout.de das brauche ich jenals ich connect mich damit mit ssh drauf
username max123456 super top secret passwort ich will kein wifi access kann man das kann man das
leer lassen enable ssh use password on the notification use ja ja passwort ist okay
das ist ich habe diesen debian diesen raspberry pi dings hier imager die neue
version habe ich noch nie verwendet komplett neu für mich
ein label raspberry pi connect was ist denn das
writing es ist ein e-mail write you race
der mensch ist gut gemacht ja muss man muss man echt sagen massive immer schon auch hier
was ist was gibt's bei add options place und wenn finde ich die jack media wenn finished
gerade wird geschrieben also mein plan ist folgender ich mal euch das jetzt noch einmal
auf wir machen das hier in den filmen oder so mein plan ist ist folgender
also px e tfdp gut jeweils unterschiedlich bios und uefi da braucht man nämlich unterschiedliche
sachen zu ipx ipx e ist quasi die pxe nur dass man http anstelle tfdp benutzen kann allerdings
für kisten die selbst noch kein native ipx e haben müssen ipx e erstmal von pxe booten
alles klar dann zu einem minimal db an installer image und von dort an das db an cloud image auf
platte die den und konflikt mit cloud in it ok so ist das gedacht von der idee
weiß ich alles wie es funktioniert und die einzelteile müsste auch zusammen
kriegen aber so alles alles in kombination vielleicht bisserl
er muss denn seine sd karte verifizieren
wird da rein gesteckt in den raspberry pi
ob es falsch rum steckt die auch über die sdk den fall drum rein jedes mal
ok netzwerk stärker sein was bei strom stecker wo ist er da
und ist er an?
Er ist an.
Exzellent.
Jetzt muss ich mich am zweiten Bildschirm mal kurz verbinden
auf meinen Router,
um dort mal zu gucken,
was das Ding für eine
IP-Adresse bekommt.
Leases.
Aha.
bis jetzt sehe ich noch nichts
jetzt sehe ich hier noch nichts aha was haben wir da ich sehe da ist ssh max
11 22 14 also das ist auf jeden fall die richtige jetzt nur torst das ist die richtige
ich habe so gerade meine router gesehen der pxe champ der hat die acht moment
der es bei repute sicher immer weil er die platte risse ist doch gar nicht da
hat sie eben eine ip geholt hat dann gedacht kein bock alter
was ist denn jetzt es bei da ist
du ein dhcp server multi die optionen setzt
das wird advanced ich habe ein dhcp server da kann das aber nicht richtig deswegen werden wir
einen dns mask daneben stellen der nicht die ip's manager sondern nur die informationen für
pxe boot raus raushaut so kann man px also kann man die hcp server weiter auf meinem
router bleiben und das pxe zeug wird von dem dns mask erledigt da sind wir was wir bei
um es ist so langsam alter was da los mit f und wie war geht doch
vielleicht doch eine ssd dran machen sollen
upgrade aber so viel installieren müssen wir ja nicht
ja wir machen einen zweiten server aber wir machen kein dhcp über den zweiten server oder
wir machen doch doch wir machen so eine art wie machen dhcp ohne ip adressen zu verteilen das
geht man kann quasi zu einem schon bestehenden dhcp server einfach nur pxe informationen liefern
so machen wir das das weiß ich auch schon wie es geht das kann ich mir copy paste das habe ich hier
aber gleich das war also wie das funktioniert weiß ich und frage ich hier den es mast kommt
so geht das das zeige ich euch gleich ach so vielleicht soll ich hier noch dabei schreiben
also das ausliefern also nx macht web server macht http zeug und dns maß macht halt ja cp
proxy heißt das mit mit px infos
was ist denn sq es cool sowas wie jay-q swiss armen auf ins back joint export
data
nicht
Von der Armkiste kann man eine x86 Kiste PXE booten.
Da wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was dagegen sprechen sollte.
Ich meine, der liefert halt x86 Bootsachen aus.
Das dürfte eigentlich kein Problem sein.
So, da haben wir geupgradet.
Wollen wir nochmal stehen?
Komm, wir rebooten nochmal.
Ne, wir geben mal eine statische IP.
Nicht, dass das Ding zwischendurch wechselt.
ETC Network Interfaction.
E, äh, äh, äh, chat, oh fuck, äh, äh, äh.
Wie konfiguriert man denn eine statische IP auf dem Raspberry Pi?
network manager nm3 kann man machen das geht über network manager
oder spd-pi. edit a connection netpla... darf ich das darüber machen?
eher nicht oder? besser nicht. kommt sich bestimmt in die quere.
netplan etc net net plan was für ein ding ist doch vom network manager install wim h top pv
des den übrigen verdächtigen darauf fahren machst du auch noch unattended installation ja wobei ich
keine unattended installation klassisch machen mit durchklicken ich lasse mir das
debian cloud image auf die platte ddn und dann per cloud in it
wie macht man das eigentlich was der tic ip
immer eine statische ip vergibt
ein wort der fuck wollen die mir sagen dass das nicht
okay also geht es doch mal network manager
und es ist also war ich doch richtig
Oh, habe ich mir gerade die Netzwerkverbindung deaktiviert?
Leute, ich glaube, ich habe mir gerade die Netzwerkverbindung deaktiviert.
Scheiße
Ups
Ey, wer kann damit ahnen
Wenn man auf activate connection geht
Und enter drückt, dass es sich dann deaktiviert
Alter
Was ist das
Okay, reicht es vielleicht
Reicht es vielleicht, wenn ich einfach nur das Kabel
Rein und raus ziehe
Geht das vielleicht, reicht es oder muss ich die Kiste neu starten
Oder bleibt es komplett deaktiviert
Und ich muss das Image neu machen
sind wir doch wieder da sind wir wieder
kabel rein rausziehen hat geholfen
scheiße das schaltet sich wieder ab im
inschneu wirklich nee oder alter
ok strom raus strom rein
ich schließe jetzt kein monitor an die dann dass lieber das image neu drauf hauen
das war jetzt richtig dumm alter
bitte nicht ausschalten
okay es geht immer noch das spricht spricht dafür dass es anscheinend funktioniert
Edit.
Äh.
Hier, da.
IPv4-Configuration.
Äh.
Manual.
Okay.
Ah.
Address.
Ach so geht das.
Okay.
Add.
1, 9, 2, 1, 2.
2.
5, 5 oder so.
Ist das frei?
ja 55 gateway 12 22 2.5 dns server auch jeder router der router gut
ipv6 können wir tatsächlich das able den jux sagen wir okay
weg
ähm
und wie
apply
reboot wirklich
pinken wir den und dann bringen wir die neue ip guck mal was als erstes anstatt kommt
ach so ist das stimmt ja das hätte bestimmt auch funktioniert aber gut fix auf jeden fall auch
also auf es geht wahrscheinlich sind da ist einfach gar nicht mehr
habe ich irgendwo vertippt vielleicht da sind wir
es haben und 50
Terminal Spatrum
S
Ich hab übrigens was sehr
Nices mir geschrieben dort
Muss ich euch mal kurz zeigen, ich hab mir das extra hier
Moment, was machen wir jetzt
Paste das hier mal rein
Alles klar
So, ich zeige euch jetzt mal was.
Passt mal auf.
Also, guckt mal, ihr kennt das doch.
Das wenn man...
SSH...
Known Hosts...
So, jetzt löschen wir den mal und tun so, als wäre der gewesen.
Okay, jetzt fällt nämlich...
Ja, jetzt fällt nämlich das SSH da drauf.
Guck.
Warum nicht?
Jetzt doof, warum fällt das SSH
da drauf nicht, wenn das ein alterer Key ist?
Ah ja, okay. Jetzt fällt das SSH,
weil
der Key sich geändert hat.
Der Server-Key. Wenn ich mir sicher bin,
würde man normalerweise machen SSH
Keygen
SSH
Keygen-R
und dann schreibst du die IP hin. Was ich jetzt gemacht habe,
ich habe hier einen Alias für die Shell
eingeführt, heißt fix ssh.
Eine Function in der Shell, fix ssh.
Und jetzt
funzt die Verbindung wieder.
Und wisst ihr, wie das
funktioniert? Das ist eigentlich
richtig sick, finde ich.
Der holt sich aus Westterm
den Scrollback-Buffer, also er holt sich
den Text aus dem Terminal.
Ähm.
Warte mal.
er holt sich den Text aus dem Terminal
greppt dort nach dieser Fehlermeldung
greppt dann dort die IP-Adresse
raus, holt sich die letzte
das letzte ausgeführte fehlgeschlagene
SSH-Kommando und dann führt
er mit der IP einen SSH-Kigern-R
aus. Theoretisch könnte
man jetzt noch sowas hier drunter machen, dann würde
er sogar das SSH neu ausführen.
Aber das braucht's nicht.
Das finde ich sehr nice.
Guck, sobald es fehlt, schlägt.
So, jetzt machen wir erstmal SSH Copy ID.
Dass man sich da ordentlich drauf einloggen kann.
Dreh ich durch.
Wart.
Der hat IDRSAZG.populiert, was der Standardmäßig nicht verwendet.
Alter, hier, was ist das?
Minus I.SSH.
ID.
Was ist denn mein
gescheiter Key hier? Der da bestimmt.
Der ist bestimmt das Beste.
God, let's do not match.
Was habe ich da für dumme Keys rumliegen, man?
Okay, dann...
ID, ID, RSA.
Komm, der geht bestimmt.
Ah ja, okay, der Pfotzt, sehr gut.
Sehr schön. So, jetzt sind wir auf der Debian Kiste drauf. Das erste, was wir jetzt brauchen ist,
ein DNS Mask, den müssen wir installieren. Ganz wichtig. Und ein Nginx müssen wir installieren.
und dann gucken wir mal ob das booten funktioniert das müssen wir relativ easy
hinkriegen hier ich lege mir schon mal eine vm an die eigentlich nur dafür da ist dass man
dass man sie bietet later linux later px px px test heißt das ding jetzt ja keine ahnung
4 CPUs brauchen wir eh nicht, äh, pflegekram. Bridge Networking machen wir mal um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen.
LS, jaja, zack.
20 Gig.
customer ist hat wer soundkarte raus wenn ich okay und damit px e booten
wir jetzt und gucken ob das prinzipiell mal funktioniert aber aus
also noch ein stream ja so dns machst da brauchen wir jetzt eine config für dns machst die habe ich
schon die habe ich schon die sieht nämlich folgendermaßen aus die müssen wir nur um die
ip-adresse anpassen etc dns maß die erstmals kommt so alles weg set paced das brauche ich erkläre es
mal kurz das habe ich schon ausprobiert also da weiß ja das prinzipiell funktioniert die ip
müssen wir nur da habe ich da habe ich einen tag oder so gebraucht bis ich das raus gekriegt habe
dann müssen wir bloß die ip anpassen ja also was das macht ist folgendes ich bin mir selbst bei
manchen sachen nicht sicher ja ich habe das tatsächlich teilweise von der ki diese dinge
habe ich tatsächlich von der ki generieren lassen hier diese teile weil ich keine ahnung wie ich das
hinkriege was funktioniert also ihr wisst schon allein wenn wenn ich kommentare drin habe dann
wisst ihr genau massive ki modus aktiviert also was das ding macht ist der guckt was für dhcp
options der klein sendet wenn der client pxe option 175 sendet dann weiß er erbootet schon
per pxe wenn die wenn der client optional sendet dann weiß er es ist ein bios boot wenn der option
6 sendet dann weiß er es ist ein 32 bit system wenn er 7 sendet weiß er dass es in 64 bit system
und 9 ist auch ein 64 bit system und danach match der danach guckt er okay wenn der tag nicht pxe
ist weil wenn der pxe ist vom pxe booten ipx e booten wenn der tag nicht die pxe ist und x86 pc
dann soll da das fürs bios laden
wenn was auch immer bcv ist keiner wenn bcv gesetz ist es passt doch gibt überhaupt keinen
sinn was mir die ei hier generiert hat oder müsste das hier oben nicht x86 wie heißen
ich bin ich habe eigentlich gedacht dass hier von egal schauen wir mal die ip 55
und hier und 55 so das ist jetzt ein dhcp server der eine ipc vergibt
das gibt's also kannst auf dhcp request antworten ohne ip der halt dem booten den
Server nur mit, wo er seine Images
findet zum Booten.
Wir gucken jetzt mal prinzipiell, ob das
überhaupt funktioniert. Wir haben noch keine Images und nix.
Aber wir können zumindest
schon mal checken.
Das ist ganz wild, ja.
Wir können zumindest schon mal checken.
Geil.
SRV, TFTP
inaccessible. Okay.
MKDir, SRV,
TFDP.
Ähm.
Okay, restart.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, ob die Kiste prinzipiell
booten würde. Also wir haben noch keine Images
oder so, aber mal schauen. Was?
Oh.
Bin ich den Store?
Macht der irgendwas?
Ah, guck mal hier.
Booty Pixel Bios.
Ja, der würde booten,
wenn eine Image da liegt.
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt ein Image.
Wir müssen nach
CD, SAV und TFTP
DNS-Mask,
Conf
und da müssen jetzt diese Images hier hin.
Warum ist hier eigentlich
WIM-Modus standardmäßig aktiviert?
Das ist doch ganz abartig.
Wim.wimrc
SetMouse
gleich
Excellent.
Achso, wir können auch noch hier
SyntaxOn machen.
Ja, so ist gut.
So, damit kann man
arbeiten.
Ja, jetzt kann ich wenigstens ordentlich markieren.
So, jetzt müssen wir
Images legen, dahin.
Wir benutzen IPXE zum Booten.
IPXE
äh, warte mal, was war das?
boot.
Oh ne, ipxe boot.pxe.org
oder sowas?
ipxe.
Dann gab es hier glaube ich boot.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe.
boot.ipxe.org
Genau. Also wir brauchen
einmal das da für
efi boot.
Und wir brauchen
Uni irgendetwas.
Ne, undi only.
Was auch immer das bedeuten soll.
Eheführ.
Gut.
Jetzt haben wir die Dateien da liegen.
Jetzt sollte der ordentlich booten.
Der sollte jetzt...
Also der kann auch nicht booten, aber der kann
IPXE booten.
Und auch, guck, IPXE startet.
So.
So, jetzt
an der Stelle hört's auf,
wo ich Ahnung habe. Dafür
habe ich schon einen Tag gebraucht, bis das funktioniert
hat. Ich kann euch auch beweisen, dass es
funktioniert.
Ich kann euch auch beweisen, dass es
funktioniert. Wenn ich jetzt hier nämlich
UEFI boote,
ich hoffe mal, ich habe jetzt kein Lister erzählt,
dann bootet er auch nach EPXE.
Das heißt, dass
auch dieser Switch BIOS EFI
funktioniert.
Guck,
EPXE bootet er.
natürlich geht es jetzt nicht weiter weil noch nichts dahinter ist aber er hat die pxe gebootet
das spricht dafür dass alles funktioniert auch mal aus also
So, ach Gott.
Vor allem wäre es wieder
die Pega.
Kann man hier sowas wie Exit machen oder so?
Ups.
Ist da aus. Nice.
So, und jetzt stellen wir das hier wieder auf Bios Boot um,
weil ich das eh zu 90% in VMs verwende.
Gut.
Jetzt haben wir das Wichtigste
schon mal. Nein, wir haben nicht das Wichtigste erledigt.
das war jetzt nicht so schwierig also ipx e bootet jetzt jetzt brauchen wir ein ipx e
file was uns ein schönes menü malt habe ich hier irgendwas in der richtung schon
drin irgendwas mit gut hier gut epx genau das müssen wir jetzt anlegen jetzt auch mit matt
in der vm das ist eine gute frage ich bin mir dann ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher ob pxe gescheit
funktioniert nochmal ausprobieren hat
ne ne hätte mich jetzt auch sehr gewundert wenn das funktioniert geht ja
auch gar nicht dass das das broadcast und macht und tut das kann ich das das
Das würde mich sehr, sehr wundern, wenn das funktionieren sollte.
Mit NAT kann das nicht funktionieren.
Aber es spricht ja nichts dagegen,
das Install zu machen und dann danach auf NAT umzustellen.
Das funktioniert ja ohne Probleme.
das stimmt wohl aber du brauchst für dhcp muss das ding ja im gleichen netz hängen
oder quasi auf switch ebene im gleichen layer 2 macht es ja nicht denkt er eine
eigene netzwerkkarte in dem eigenen netz da gehen keine broadcasts raus und kommen keine zurück
so
okay das heißt wir brauchen jetzt ein boot ipx wir machen jetzt mal was einfaches wir versuchen mal
wir versuchen mal zwei sachen erst mal dass er überhaupt ein menü bekommen ja
genau ich lasse jetzt auch netboot xy das war mein plan ich lasse jetzt netboot xyz mal booten
zum testen so also ipxee example netboot xyz gibt es da was
was man auf
open code sagt er jetzt weil die meine ganzen sachen ich nutze abgeschaltet die kostenlos
okay ich brauche eine ipx eine gut punkt ipx e datei die mir ein auswahl menü gibt und darin
kann ich local boot oder netboot xyz auswählen und guten mal gucken was chat gpd dazu sagt jetzt wird
vibe admin machen wir heute ok start menü epx e boot lokal system booten timeout default local
target chain auto free ok das liest sich gar nicht so doof das werden wir etwas customizen
was chat gpt hier zusammen gewurschtelt hat also so einen komischen start tag ach so hier
goto goto start können wir machen das ist okay wir machen das anders das kommt weg menü
epix e boot heißt das ding einfach item wir müssen da keine sprüche malen so wir nennen
1 nennen wir kann ein boot local boot local netboot xyz das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut
als name reboot neustart das kann ich ehrlich gesagt brauche ich nicht das kann ich einfach
mit eintippen und gut ist so tschüss timeout 10 sekunden fünf sekunden reichen default local
local boot local habe ich das genannt gut local
oder oder go to start nee wir wollen kann man da und und drinnen machen wenn oder oder geht
dass ich sage und und
go to target
local exited einfach
starte netboot
xyz, ok
chain auto freeboot
netboot xp
ähm, ich würde
ehrlich gesagt lieber lokales netboot
xyz booten anstatt ins internet zu gehen an der stelle aber wir probieren es mal aus ob das ob das sinn hinhaut
So jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob da jetzt ein menü kommt
Post check guckte mal da ein menü
Manchmal ist er ganz praktisch
soll erst mal testen ob local boot funktioniert
die local boot funktioniert
not found logisch ist ja nichts drauf
der netboot xyz operation not supported good not boot
no aha no more network moment moment der ruft sich keine moment der ruft sich
keine IP ab oder?
PotatoBob, wir haben nicht mal ansatzweise irgendwas
Gescheites hier am Start.
Wir brauchen hier irgendwie die, der
holt sich keine IP.
Netboot
IPXE
Example Menu
oder Example, einfach
Einfach
Da war es eine hässliche
Seite.
Boah, mein Auge.
gibt es da nicht irgendwie gibt es da nicht irgendein minimalbeispiel oder so vielleicht dafür
sample ipx file
ok irgendwie erst beste github gedöns
ok meinetwegen peter bolsch
ich will kein iso image ich will einfach wissen wie dieses komische menü aussehen muss
aha guck mal da guck mal da dhcp muss man da hinschreiben dhcp
Wo schreibt man das denn hin?
Jetzt bei jedem
Bei jedem dieser Dinger?
Ne, das kann man bestimmt oben reinschreiben
Hier, DHCP
Gucken wir mal, was passiert
Zack
Ich lese den Chat, klar
So
netboot
oder holt er sich eine ip der holt es der hat sich schon ein ip geholt
der muss sich eine ip geholt haben wie soll er sonst wie soll er sonst das hier
geht das von uns nicht das war das chat gpt da zusammen gebastelt hat gibt es
gibt es die möglichkeit ipx e boot iso kann man die iso booten
laut in iso aufwahl josef
zahnbutt
zahnbutt notice kreis gut url iso
ja das ist doch gut so das war ja doch so sahen gut sahen gut hier fehlt keck
wait aller machen wir mal so was wie man die px e file set war er wird oder so
was machen variabel sind gut menü
set set boot menü und ja sowas hier das machen wir nämlich so was hier sagen wir jetzt set server ip
das wird das nicht immer jedes mal rein tippen muss 192 168 2.55 mail condition brauchen wir
nicht bei uns richtig richtig man muss einfach nur mit dem richtigen mindset daran gehen ist
ja noch wie das ist wenn man gar nicht für möglich wenn man es überhaupt nicht
zulässt dass es kaputt gehen kann dann geht doch nichts kaputt server ip ok und
jetzt was machen wir da isos oder so isos netboot ja moment da muss ich jetzt
erst einmal dahin hier war www html mk dir isos wie greifst du jetzt darauf zu auf was
was weißt du dass hier das ist ein rest bei der peinlich per sass hat hoffen
Du hast kein Portokoll angegeben, das ist richtig. Das stimmt schon, ich glaube das ist falsch, ja.
Aber ich muss erst mal das netboot xyz ISO runterladen.
copy download link wie cd isos regatt net boot xyz iso das heißt jetzt gehen wir wieder nach
shv tfdp boot und jetzt sagen wir http://isos.net boot xyz iso
So machen wir das und dann hoffen wir mal, dass es funktioniert.
er versucht sich irgendwelche komischen dinge abzurufen
was auch immer er versucht keine ahnung von meinem router versuchte die sich abzurufen
das immer net buddh xyz am start das ist doch extrem nice aber das ist ja nicht das ziel
net buddh xyz zu booten der ziel ist ein eigenes linux zu booten und dann das debian cloud image
zu installen aber prinzipiell funktioniert er schon mal das ist ja ganz gut so jetzt brauchen
wir so was wie sowas wie install so und jetzt bin ich mir jetzt habe ich keinen plan wie das
funktioniert wie bootet man ein debian oder generell nennen linux ipx e ipx e
boot debian irgendwas mit dem kölner oder so muss man da glaube angeben
buch von form i px oder mal hier unten gab es auch was debian akku mal hier
können und dann gut ich brauche jetzt so ein rand ist image genau das müssen wir
uns jetzt noch generieren das können wir uns allerdings nicht auf dem raspberry
generieren weil das keine x86 system ist vielleicht können wir das in docker
machen muss man mal gucken
so ich bin wieder da also wir brauchen irgendwie sowas hier debian also können
so lass mal kurz in mich gehen wir laden das ganze per http schon mal wir können
das ja schon mal vorbereiten und jetzt hier quasi server ip
dann machen wir dann machen wir so ein verzeichnis würde ich sagen können wir
hier noch eine variable machen sowas wie wie wie eine ahnung folder oder so oder irgendwie
es folgt keine ahnung es folgt wird dann wie nennen wir den ordner installer installer image
oder installen dann was install image install image install os folder linux und jetzt der
körner in id und dann hier jetzt muss man eine ram disk bauen das wird was ein patrick hast du
im docker ein komplettes linux kannst aber weiter ja ja aber ich muss den kram irgendwie
du verboten also du hast im docker container kein komplettes linux der kabel ist vom haus
system aber eine rand ist bauen die dann unter slash boot liegt das müsste eigentlich
funktionieren müssen wir mal gucken das probieren jetzt gleich mal aus
13 GitHub-Sterne seit gestern.
Ey, das ist echt gut.
Pock.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir
ein Debian-Image bauen.
Können wir das nicht
testweise
mit einem schon bestehenden Debian-Image machen, wo wir uns das rausholen.
Debian-Init-ID. Gibt es da nicht schon irgendwas Fertiges?
aha guck mal hier linux in it rd die bringen uns nichts weil ich für den
installer sind ich will einfach noch gucken ob das guten funktioniert okay
und geht set und das andere heißt linux okay das heißt wir machen jetzt hier
ein mkdir wie habe ich das genannt install image install image we get in
it rd und linux kernel
bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
ach so moment es kann ja so nicht funktionieren muss ja hier noch
einen eintrag machen ihr install local net boot install install
soll jetzt noch mal guten wir werden heute auf das kann ich euch sagen
ein paar boot install
das boot in den db an install das wollte das will ich ja nicht weil einfach nur gucken ob es funktioniert
so könnte man ein db an installer booten
ein schlecht aber das will ich ja nicht will kann db an installer booten ich will
einen db an image ein minimales remdesk image guten von dem aus ich dann in db an cloud image
direkt auf die platte dd ich will ja nicht jedes mal diesen installer durchklicken und
installieren müssen das muss viel schneller geht soll er viel schneller gehen aber prinzipiell
Prinzipiell funktioniert das schon mal.
Jetzt müssen wir eine eigene Linux-Körnel und so eine RAM-Disk-Geschichte bauen dafür.
PXE für Windows 11, ganz ehrlich, das würde ich mir erst gar nicht geben.
Da hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf, da würde ich durchdrehen.
Du könntest natürlich auch den Installer nutzen, dem so eine Antwort-Datei geben.
Ne, ne, wir machen das jetzt komplett selbst.
Wenn schon, dann richtig.
Können auch einfach Demo gestalten.
Was?
Habe ich das nicht vorhin installiert?
Anscheinend nicht.
Muss mal kurz Licht anmachen.
Sekunde.
Home Automation öffnen.
Ansicht, Decke einschalten.
Exzellent, schon viel besser.
So, wir bauen jetzt ein eigenes Linux-Image.
Okay, Docker run.
Debian Trixi.
Debian Trixi ist schon mal sehr gut.
Okay, wie funzt sowas?
Wir wollen ja auch einen SSH-Server haben, wenn wir da reinbooten.
Up, Install, Drop hier.
Das kenne ich.
Drop, Update.
habt install completion
install wie heißt es tropf tropf ja ja ja ja nicht bier ja genau habt install tropf bier
ob er in den tram fs also was sie jetzt machen will ist ich will mir ein eigenes linux ist so
ein initial rem disk linux bauen was ich dann guten kann wo dann schon ein paar sachen drin
sind mit der ich dann das db an cloud image quasi auf die platte dd und per cloud in den
konfigurieren soweit so weit in der theorie mal gucken alle was das denn was will das hier von
mir die selekte layout matching machine was was willst du von mir englisch utf 8 was ist denn das
wollen wir wollen eigentlich ein deutsches keyboard set haben
das mal neu machen aber gibt es da gibt es auch german german 64
Ihr habt doch gesagt 64.
1.
UTF-8.
Alter, was will denn das noch alles?
Ja, ein Guess.
Das wird auch ein Busybox.
So.
Habe ich jetzt unter Boot schon irgendwas?
Update?
Init RAMFS minus U
ist es, glaube ich.
Nee, ich habe ja kein Kernel-Zeug und so
installiert, weil wir im Docker-Container sind.
Das braucht man normalerweise nicht, aber
wie installiert man unter Debian
ein Kern? Linux?
Minus?
Headers?
Ne, wie heißt das?
Search Linux?
Irgendwas mit Linux heißen die Dinger.
Und ich habe kein
Less installiert. Es wird ja immer schlimmer.
ein sie die lux image 612 was ist der standard können ja das ist ja
wahrscheinlich an sein
das da ist wahrscheinlich der richtige linux image die gibt es muss doch da so
ein generic package geben linux image install linux image den default köln
linux image amd 64
das ganz anderes kann ich das auch auf dem raspberry pi machen
ab install linux image amd 64
Kann ich auch auf dem Raspberry Pi einen AMD 64 Kernel installieren?
Ich meine, einen Buden kann ich davon nicht, aber installieren.
Und Search.
ARM 64.
Nee, es geht nicht.
Wäre ja auch irgendwie unsinnig.
So, habe ich jetzt hier unter
Wut was?
Ah, guck mal da. Da haben wir die Dinger.
Jetzt kann ich ja Update in der DramaFS
machen. Ja, genau.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Okay, okay. Sehr nice.
Sehr nice.
Excellent, excellent.
ok wie bauen wir das jetzt also erstmal brauchen wir einen authorize key file dass ich mich per ssh
dann drauf einloggen kann also ein job ja ubuntu für ubuntu gibt es meistens bessere guides
install drop in etwa haben wir gemacht das brauchen wir nicht wir wollen damit nichts
anlocken okay etc job erinnert muss das dahin das mal kurz gucken etc job erinnert ramfs job
bier authorized at your public key ja gut man public key den gibt es ja noch gar nicht ssh
keygen.
Die habe ich nicht.
Upt-Install-SSH.
Nee, Open-SSH-Server.
Geht das einfach auch so?
Okay.
SSH-Keygen.
Okay, das wäre jetzt
ziemlich dämlich, ehrlich gesagt.
Hier drinnen auf einen zu generieren,
in dem Docker-Container.
Nehmen wir einfach mal einen der bestehenden, würde ich sagen.
ssh idee habe hier eigentlich idrs ab max ed porgas das klingt gut das wollen
wir haben max ed porgas da muss die datei hin ein bin ich muss mir das alles
merken was ich hier in dem docker container machen es muss ja nachher in
docker file irgendwie packen können und dann kann ich auf knopfdruck mir immer eine neue
ram fs generieren eigentlich sehr nice so hier ssh key max add poggers jetzt updaten wir die ram disk
Crypt Setup, das uninstall ich einfach wieder.
Upt, Remove, Crypt Setup, das brauch ich da nicht.
Ich will da nichts anlocken oder so.
Okay, das ist doch schon mal gar nicht schlecht.
Paukt das denn so?
Wir versuchen jetzt mal davon zu booten, okay?
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Dazu muss ich mir jetzt irgendwie vom Docker-Container was runterkopieren.
chat
wie kopiert man sich aus dem docker container gescheit was raus
doch cp da muss aber da installiert sein dass das funktioniert geht das
pp running container
locker ps locker cp und dann einfach so was hier probieren wir mal einfach mal
testweise wir machen wir hier in repo mk dir pxe und pxe bootcamp hätte das
eigentlich heißen müssen locker locker cp und jetzt hier ist es gibt kein auto
komplett für der mtc haus korb das prinzipiell kopiert ok von nice haus
okay wir machen das gleiche in den docker file das machen das gleiche
docker fall sonst sonst ist es doch nichts
also was habe ich jetzt gemacht viel ist es ja nicht gewesen
ob es jetzt bin ich auf falschen kiste
bin grad verwirrt war das da oben muss ich zu machen sonst sonst komme ich
durcheinander hier doch erstellt also was haben wir nicht brauchen wir nicht
brauchen wir nicht deshalb installiert okay wir bauen wir bauen wir brauchen
einen docker file locker fallen die erste mal rom bild ja ja genau ganz
toll. From Debian Trixi. Run, apt, update. Das ist erstmal das erste, was wir machen.
Dann sagen wir apt install shop here. Run, Moment, wir müssen sogar noch sagen,
dass er das automatisch machen soll. So. Äh, apt, dann haben wir gesagt remove, script, setup.
dann haben wir gesagt ab install linux image amd 64 dann haben wir das hier angelegt mit
dem inhalt drin mit diesem inhalt drin sekunde da ob das funks was ich hier
bau
so wie ich und das da rein da haben wir die datei
habe ich sonst noch irgendwas wichtiges gemacht?
Ich glaube nicht.
Achso, ja doch.
Dann müssen wir noch sagen
Run
Update
Init RAM FS
Minus U
war es glaube ich. So, jetzt gucken wir mal, was
passiert hier. Docker
Build
ja keine ahnung wii xe boot
ach was habe ich dann wieder verkackt
was genau hast du jetzt für probleme dem jan
was ist jetzt das problem
eben ging das doch noch
ja aber warum geht die install nicht macht doch gar keinen sinn
Hä?
Soll ich zweimal Update machen?
Okay, keine Ahnung. Zweimal Update
Funds. Einmal war zu wenig.
Keck, wait.
Achso und jetzt will ich ja den Kram da raus kopieren.
Ok, jetzt kann ich hier oben zu machen, weil mehr habe ich hier oben auch nicht gemacht.
epos px e boots so jetzt mal docker an px eben ein eigenes gebautes px e boot image haben wir
denn unter etc job wir in der tram fs eine authorize key feiligen haben wir mit dem
richtigen key drin sehr schön das heißt jetzt muss ich mir hier was raus kopieren
wir machen mal ein bild bild punkt sh locker bild
bin.bash
So, wir machen erst ein Docker-Build
und danach machen wir ein Docker-CP.
Jetzt kommt das Ding, da weiß ich
das Kommando für nicht.
Docker-CP. Ne, erstmal müssen wir ein Docker-Run
noch machen.
Docker-Run.
Moment, wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit?
Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt, wie kriege ich denn aus gescheit
aus Docker was rauskopiert?
Moment, wir haben doch da was, wir haben doch da was
Wir haben doch hier ein
Build-Skript, was genau sowas macht
Bild.sh
Also, was machen wir denn da?
docker bild machen wir da doch aha
ist der pfeiffer
locker create name xe boot
PXE
Boot
und jetzt sage ich
Docker CP
Gut, dass wir für alles schon mal irgendwas haben.
Das war aber nicht minus minus Q
Gibt es Docker CP
minus R? Gibt es sowas?
Dass ich sagen kann, ich will
PXE Boot
Alles slash Boot
was ist output dir
okay kann ich einfach sagen ich will alles dahin kopieren das muss man mal das muss
jetzt mal ausprobieren ob das ob das funst ob man das aber das machen kann ob also wir sagen
jetzt wir wollen von nicht von px e boot von diesem hässlichen docker namen
wo wir kopieren slash boot quasi direkt hier hin und da war nichts nach der
f0 halten oder so ok das funks schon mal nett
ok da sind die files ich brauch excellent
hier das brauche bild und sh so und jetzt allerdings für px e boot dahin genau dann
machen wir r-f punkt slash boot dir nehmen
was richtig was aus dem alten skript kopieren nämlich dass da das ist six
hat und zwar was das am anfang des skripts macht ist das wechselt in das
verzeichnis in dem das best script selbst liegt das heißt alles was ich
danach ausführe ist relativ zum skript das immer sehr praktisch so kann er gut
machen doch cp mit der kram rüber kopiert hier und dann wieder docker rm
pxe boot so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das was ich da gebastelt habe
funktioniert bild ca mod plus x bild wird wie das war es schon tatsächlich weil es
von da haben wir da haben wir unsere karten geschichten die wir brauchen top
So, wir kopieren uns den Kram von boot init rd boot vm linux.
Kopieren wir uns nach max add.
Was hat mein Raspberry Pi?
55, genau.
nach max 55 und dann nach war www hat ach da darf ich nicht reinschreiben oder war ww install image
da darf ich nicht da darf ich nicht rein kopieren
Moment, muss ich das auch mal richtig machen.
Ah ja, Permission, Permission Denied.
Ähm,
Chat, wir machen es uns jetzt mal einfach.
Machen es uns jetzt mal einfach.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Wir loggen uns per Route ein.
Es gab doch auch irgendwie so einen Trick,
dass man, ähm,
SCP
But pseudo first.
Da gab es doch so einen Trick.
Den ich hier gerade noch nicht aus dem Kopf weiß.
The eternal pain.
Okay.
Ist gut.
Ja, alles okay.
Das kann man so machen.
Kann man so machen.
scp schreiben wir hier in mein heimatverzeichnis rein
ich bin im falschen verzeichnis
okay das von uns das lässt sich kopieren gut dann packen wir das noch in das bildskript rein
scp von boot in it rd wir machen hier mal leute wir machen hier mal ein sternchen hin dass der
immer wenn der kram sich anders nennt auch match ich hoffe das funktioniert so das kopierte hin
Danach machen wir SSH hier hin.
Und dann sagen wir dort sudo mv.
Wir machen das in den Extraordner hier.
mkdir init-rd.
So ist es besser.
ok so da kann man nämlich sagen wir musen einfach von internet rd sternchen alles nach
war
www.html
install
image
Ob das Funds, was ich hier gestrickt habe?
Okay, gucken wir mal.
Bild.
Aha, aha.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Postchamp.
war www.html
html install image
da ist das Zeug, perfekt
Moment, Moment, Moment, ich will aber nicht, dass das so heißt
da muss ich jedes Mal anpassen, ne, ne, ne, warte mal hier, m Sternchen
wir machen das anders, wir, komm wir machen das einfach
zweimal, ist doch egal, sudo, so wir kopieren
die hier
init
init rd
.image
Sternchen
kopieren wir hin unter
init rd
r
und
vm linux
kopieren wir
unter
vm linux
dass das immer gleich heißt auch beim updaten sonst kriegst ja durch im Kopf
mal gucken ob das Funz was ich gebaut habe
passt exzellent Leute exzellent xxx jetzt dreht er komplett durch
so in rd vm linux
geschaut was jetzt passiert beim boot jetzt bin ich selbst mal gespannt
install operation not permitted moment moment ich hatte habe ich mich irgendwie verschrieben
habe ich mich verschrieben wenn er sagt operation not permitted ist irgendwas hier falsch was ist
denn falsch 12 255 install image slash in rd ob bittet guck dir mal hier
ca mod 777 ist voller von welcher dann alles ja ja ja natürlich immer 77 so auf
alles security brauche ich keine
da guck mal an da bootet und es bietet sogar in meinen ssh server ist das nicht toll und da sind
wir auf dem ram fs genau das was ich haben will und jetzt hätte ich gerne so was wie install was
es ja gibt schon irgendwie setup ok setup script was mir jetzt quasi einen dialog anbietet willst
du jetzt das Cloud-Image runterladen und dann
dede mir das auf die erste Festplatte, die du gefunden
hast. Da muss ich das Init-RAM-FS
allerdings noch ein bisschen customizen.
Also ich mache jetzt quasi da in diesem Menü
das, was
normalerweise man halt in einem Webinterface
bei der Cloud macht.
Wir schauen übrigens mal, ob man per SSH
draufkommt. 2.141
SSH
1.4.1
Hm.
also host key verification fix ssh ist es nicht praktisch
wenn ich max gut da sind wir wir sind in unserer sind per ssh in unserer
internet ram ist das nicht nice da können wir jetzt nämlich da brauchst du
nämlich gar kein monitor anschließen theoretisch kannst jetzt per ssh
weitermachen das ist sogar noch besser als ein webinterface bei einem cloud an peter
weil das alles vom terminal aus machen kannst so exquisite also das von schomer das finde ich
äußerst nice.
Jetzt, Chat, jetzt mal in mich gehen.
Wie macht man das jetzt am besten?
Ich brauche
in meinem Installer
in meinem Install-Image brauche ich ein Skript.
Ein Skript,
was mir
sowas hier sinngemäß macht.
LSBLK
nach FZF.
Achso.
LSBLK nach FZF.
Sowas in der Richtung.
ja wo ich dann die disc auswählen kann und sagen ich will auf dieser dieser disk installieren so
sondern sondern ist so eine art menü will ich da jetzt haben ja noch besser ich weiß was wir
machen vorher machen wir eine abfrage ob wir debian stable testing oder unstable haben wollen
würde ich sagen.
Rust-CLI-Interface, Quatsch.
Wir machen das mit Shell.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ich habe eine Idee. Ich habe eine Idee, Chat.
Wir bauen uns
in unser Init-RAM
FS
bauen wir uns ein Skript ein.
Okay? Ein Skript
nenne ich jetzt einfach mal setup.sh
oder setup oder so.
Wir bauen uns dann ein Skript ein, was nichts anderes macht, wie ein weiteres Skript von meinem Webserver runterzuladen.
Der Hintergrund ist, ich will ja nicht jedes Mal mein Boot-Image anpassen, wenn ich Änderungen an dem Skript mache.
Also wir bauen uns da quasi sowas hier sinngemäß.
Das legen wir einfach hier in root.
Wim.Skript.sh, beste Benamung überhaupt.
Das muss allerdings ein bin.sh sein, weil das ja in der Busybox läuft.
Da machen wir sowas wie rm.slash script.sh.
Wobei ich nenne es nicht Script, ich nenne es wirklich Setup.
Script.
Setup.
Setup.sh nennen wir es.
So, das andere nennen wir Script.
Kommt wieder ins Install.
Install.sh.
Okay.
So.
Ich weghette mir dann.
HTTP.
1.2.55.
Slash.
Install.sh.
Weghette ich mir vom Server.
Dann.
chmod.
Plus x.
Install.
Punkt sh.
Und dann.
Skript, ne Install hab ich es genannt
Install.sh ausführen
Fertig, mehr macht das Skript
Was ich in mein
Ähm, auch mit hardcoded
IP und sowas, ja
Mehr macht das nicht
Die IP von dem Server
Darf sich halt nicht ändern, aber
Eine statische IP dafür, das ist okay
So, mehr macht das nicht
So
Ähm
Warte mal, ich bin ja auch blöd
Guck dir mal
Ich, ich depp
Setup.sh
Das hat hier überhaupt nichts zu suchen
Das, das muss ins Image rein
Also das muss im Docker-File
Also es muss hier irgendwie eine Datei mal angelegt werden
wir löschen das vorher dass es nicht in docker mit rein kopiert wird
so also das kommt jetzt hier hin wenn wir es hier setup punkt sh
so sehr mod plus 6.sh jetzt gehen wir unser docker file so wo müssen jetzt custom scripts
hin wo muss da muss ich jetzt noch mal docker starten docker wo müssen custom scripts hin die
in die in der trame fs eingebunden werden sollen da gab es irgendwo hucks irgendwas mit hucks
etc in der trame fs tools
das war woanders
user share das klingt gut user share in the tram fs tools scripts genau dahin
war das falsch jetzt richtig hucks genau da sind sachen trenne die letzte die dann
letztendlich in das image kopiert werden das heißt wir brauchen jetzt ein skript
ok da mussten wir fragen war chad chad gpt haupt copy customer script into in den tram fs und dem
Das ist ein klassischer Debian-Init-Gramm-FS-Move.
Alter, Chat, gib bitte halt.
Das ist gelaber immer.
Script-Example, make it executable.
Create a hook.
Ja, genau.
ETC.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das muss ich.
ich habe sowas schon mal gemacht was in der internet das muss hier unter user
chat gpt erzählt ist okay aber der rest der rest ist eigentlich sehr übertrieben
jetzt also war mal hier die copy files nennen wir das einfach mal okay install
wim copy files so und da würde man jetzt kommt das ist alles blödsinn das
Das kann man so lassen.
Vielleicht sollten wir aber tatsächlich noch
das da. Das da könnten wir vielleicht noch
inkluden. Weil ansonsten gibt es ja
CopyExec nicht.
User-Local-Bin-Skript.
Ich hoffe,
das meckert jetzt beim Bilden von der
E3-Best, dass es das da nicht gibt.
Root-Slash
setup.sh
Wir kopieren das
nach
user
bin setup.sh
Und das Ganze kopieren wir
nochmal nach setup
und nochmal nach s. Weil ich kenne mich,
ich bin faul beim Tippen.
Irgendwann will ich nur noch s eingeben.
Und das ist gut.
So.
Update init ramfs
minus u.
Und? Kackts ab?
Ich hoffe, es kackt ab.
Es kackt nicht ab.
Habe ich das nicht ausführbar gemacht? Kann das sein?
CRMOD plus X Copy Files.
Ah, guck mal, jetzt kackt es ab.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Das heißt, es kackt ab.
Das heißt, wir wissen, dass es funktioniert.
Klingt jetzt doof, ist in dem Fall aber so.
probieren wir das mal raus so das muss jetzt in unserer docker file irgendwie
rein
chat wie macht man multiline zeug in dem docker file mit mit mit mit hier docs
oder also wir wollen multiline string doch ach komm komm leute ich weiß wie
wir es machen scheiß drauf wir machen das überhaupt nicht ins docker file rein
Wir legen das einfach hier hin.
Äh, Copy Files.
So.
CRMod plus X.
Copy Files.
Da.
Docker File.
Äh, Copy.
Das kommt weg.
Das kommt ganz ohne immer hin.
Copy.
ob die files nach user user share in ram fs tools hook da soll das hin
wir programmieren heute gar nicht wir machen heute vibe administration vibe admin wobei
das meiste ist ja von mir ausgedacht aber manchmal kann man chat gpt fragen so copy
copy file moment gut setup ja moment moment das muss ich ja davor auch noch hin kopieren
Setup.sh
Das muss ja auch noch kopiert werden.
Wim.
Dockerfile.
Setup.sh
Muss nach
root.
Okay.
Passt das, was ich hier gestrickt habe?
Schauen wir mal.
Build.
Generating.
Okay, das hat funktioniert.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
SRV?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Install.
Install Image.
Ja, 15 Uhr, das sind die richtigen Images.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Wenn ich es richtig gemacht habe,
habe ich jetzt einen Setup.sh.
was sich nicht ausführen lässt aber es müsste da sein install ja okay okay okay
wir müssen noch was hinterher schießen
und zwar ein sudo ch mod minus er 77 77
html okay so da habe ich immer die richtigen berechtigung
okay gut
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert post champ chat meint ihr
geht so haben wir ein setup punkt sh
ab da ist es es funktioniert nicht aber wir haben es in unserer in unser skript
eingebaut in unserer in der tram fs eingebaut easy richtig hyper easy easy
so sieht's aus und wisst ihr was das gute daran ist jetzt ist ja was das gute daran
ist. Jetzt muss ich
mein InitramFS nicht mehr
customizen,
weil
ich kann das Skript,
was der hier abruft,
kann ich jetzt hier customizen
auf meinem Server.
InstallImage
oder was? Moment mal, was ruf ich ab?
Moment.
Setup.sh
install.sh rufe ich ab also
seamod plus x install.sh install.sh vim install.sh so und da drin machen wir jetzt
nur mal einfach dass man sieht dass es geht ls minus la sonst nichts ok
zack so switchen und jetzt ls minus la quasi gewollte code injection so
kann ich hier was ausführen meine elit kam fs und aus kürze schon so jetzt ist die große preisfrage
wie krieg ich
Ich
Wie kriege ich jetzt einen schönen dialog
Wo ich auswählen kann
Also wo ich auswählen kann, welche Debian-Version ich haben will und dann auf welcher Disk ich
installieren will.
Okay, Debian-Version sollte eigentlich relativ easy sein.
In der DramaFS ist das, was dein Bootloader startet, das ist dein Linux-Kernel plus eine
Remdisk und das was von dort dann gestartet wird, das startet dann dein eigentliches Linux System.
Also dein Bootloader bootet in den Kernel in der InitramFS, macht da ein paar Dinger und
dann startet es dein eigentliches System. Und man kann diese InitramFS auch benutzen,
um da Custom Sachen drin zu machen, zum Beispiel ein Installer Script oder so hinlegen.
Und das machen wir gerade
Okay, ich will jetzt sowas hier machen
Echo minus E
Stable
Testing
Sit
Ich bin blöd
Backslash endlich
Slash, wie kommen wir auf Flash
So, und das Ganze
Mit Dialog hast du das Shell-Auswahlmenü.
Ich würde FZF nehmen.
Dialog.
Habe ich, bin ich mir ganz sicher,
habe ich das schon mal verwendet?
Nein, nein, wir machen das mit FZF.
FZF ist mir lieber.
Kannst sogar Fuzzy-Searchen hier an der Stelle.
Oder Dialog.
Wie benutzt man Dialog?
Linux Dialog
Auswahlmenü
alle was für eine was für schwarze magie ist das denn
wir machen das mit fzf leute fzf ist viel lieber
da muss wir müssen doch unsere unsere rand ist anpassen
wir müssen fzf installieren wir müssen fzf installieren fzf
okay wir machen das umgedreht wir inszenieren den linux server hier oben
weil das dauert immer eine weile wenn sie den job ja auch als eigenes und das
machen wir auch und das machen wir auch und dann den rest machen wir dann nur
hier install fzf gibt es noch irgendwas was wir brauchen warum ein doppel update
weil es nicht funktioniert hat mit einem keine ahnung warum vielleicht war das
auch einfach nur was temporäres ich lasse jetzt doppelt das update hat
so und jetzt müssen wir unsere copy files wenn ich fzf installiere wohl liegt das dann
schön ist es eine go anwendung user user bin fzf
copy files
user bin fzf mal kopieren wir machen das mal lokal ja wir machen das jetzt mal lokal also
bei einmal einmal bilden können wir schon da nicht weiß jetzt weil ich jetzt verstehe ist
ich muss jetzt ja aber stehe ich kann ein bisschen auf dem schlauch wie man das jetzt
weitermachen erst mal gucken wie man gescheites auswahlmenü macht die discs
also ich will so was wie lsb lkf aber halt was wir weib admin noch mal ein
bisschen
ich will lsb lkf pfeifen
Und eine Liste bekommen mit allen Root-Disk-Devices.
Also nicht SDH1-ETC.
Okay, mal gucken, was Chat-GPDR draus macht.
Okay.
Also man muss sagen, für solche Sachen ist Chat-GPDR nicht verkehrt.
Ja, das ist gut.
ZRAM.
Okay, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Nur, nur Type-Disk.
gibt es so was wie type vielleicht teil doch disc exquisite xl z ram also z ram brauchen
wir nicht heißt im endeffekt ich will da jetzt minus vz ram weg erstmal grep grep
startet mit disk ok und dann crept-vzram ja und jetzt habe ich meine disk zum auswählen
da mal hier drauf will ich installieren dann muss ich jetzt nur noch das ganze mit awk rausholen
dollar 2 sda exzellent okay sehr schön lsb lk brauchen wir glaube ich auch noch das ist da
auch nicht standardmäßig dabei oder lsb lk natürlich nicht auch zu einfach lsb lk wo liegt das
Which?
LSBLK.
User Bin.
Oh, nice.
Wenn alles unter User Bin liegt, soll mir das recht sein.
User Bin, LSBLK.
Build.
Okay.
So.
Warum AWK?
Keine Ahnung, weil mir gerade AWK schneller eingefallen ist.
Tieferen Sinn hat es nicht.
Also, dann.
Bauen wir doch mal unser Skript.
bauen wir doch mal unser Skript zusammen.
Wir können jetzt schon mal noch einmal rebooten,
dass wir die richtige NETRAMFS mit FZF und LSBLK und so drin haben.
Install.
Okay. Gut.
Wir können uns übrigens auch wieder,
weil das so nice per SSH funktioniert,
verbinden hier per SSH.
und zwar auf die 141 wieder.
Es ist so nice, dass diese Initial RAM Disk,
dass das SSH-Funds, fix SSH.
So, hier, zack.
Also, wir müssen jetzt,
also einmal das hier brauchen wir gleich
und, okay, Moment, wie machen wir das?
ins install punkt sh brauchen wir install punkt sh da kommt jetzt kein
ls minus 1 1 sondern da kommt erst einmal kommt oben set minus minus minus
o ok lass mal überlegen ob ich das aus dem kopf raus kriegt was ist exit on
error printe was du machst und und wenn ein kommando in der peip fällt auch raus
ich weiß nicht ich weiß nur dass es ist als auch im kopf was die optionen bedeuten
und und sowas hier wollen wir auch haben also aber so was sie hier
man man clear davor so ist distro gleich echo minus stable testing fzf genau gut
also was hier halt gleich fünf reicht ok distro das gibt es eine auswahl select
haben wir noch mal einen debug echo selected distro gleich dollar bistro da kommen jetzt
auch für den stable testing sind wir machen debian only was anderes installiere ich nicht
Obuntu braucht dann auch wieder andere Cloud-Init-Configs und sowas, das ist eklig
Ebian reicht mir, kein Ubuntu
So, Distro, jetzt müssen wir die Disk auswählen
Disk
Gleich
hier muss erst mal
type name size model krebs und disc wir machen hier auch wieder halt 5
Jetzt gehen wir nochmal aus hier, Selected, Disk, Ups, Disk, Disk, die richtige Disk ist
aber eigentlich mit einem dev davor dev
der windows 11 ganz vergesst fertig war so steff und dann kommt die des kinden
dran okay jetzt schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert also wir sind hier wieder
auf der kiste drauf setup wir können auswählen sit testing stable
jetzt habe ich abgebrochen sehr schlau stable disk und jetzt muss ich das cloud
image drauf die den ach das ist schön
und jetzt jetzt werde installation fast schon fertig so bäume bäume auch hier
Die eigentliche Installation fehlt noch.
Ich habe da doch ein Skript vorbereitet, Leute.
Hahaha.
Exzellente Skripts.
Hier, passt mal auf.
Guck dir mal da.
Ein massive Sixhead-Skript habe ich doch hier dafür.
install image update punkt sh guckte mal hier was wir hier haben ist ja was das macht nein
das ist ja nicht aber das erzähle ich euch jetzt das lädt immer die neueste debian daily version
runter und zwar für sit stable und testing wie es das macht ist folgendermaßen das gehört vom
debian ftp die release info da kommt zeige euch wie das aussieht
tricksy tricksy guck da kommt sowas hier zurück da krepp ich mir codename raus
dann gehe ich hier auf die cloud images tricksy und hol mir hier diese zahl raus
die Versionsnummer. Das ist voll durch die Brust
ins Auge, aber es funktioniert.
Dann hole ich mir diese Zahl hier raus, aus dem
Image,
dass noch eine übrig bleibt
und dann
downloade ich
das letzte
aktuelle Cloud-Image
und jetzt kommt der Trick.
Jetzt ist FIFAT-Time.
Wobei, das muss ich auch noch in meinen
Initial-RAM-FS einbauen. Jetzt ist FIFAT-Time.
So, ich lade mir das Image runter als TAR.xz, einfach weil es kleiner ist.
Dann enttare ich das.
Okay.
Und dann LZ4-e ich es wieder.
Also ich wandle das quasi um von einem TAR.xz zu einem LZ4.
Warum zu einem LZ4?
Weil LZ4 sehr schnell dekomprimierbar ist.
Das heißt, ich spare einfach massig Bandbreite, auch wenn ich mir später die Install-Images von meinem HTTP ziehe.
Du hast gerade Distro als Distro-Trixi angegeben.
Ja und? Ist doch richtig?
Wo ist das Problem?
Es heißt so.
Aktuelle Debian Release heißt so
Trixie ist der
Dinosaurier glaube ich
Ist Distro nicht Stable?
Die aktuelle Stable Distributoren ist Trixie
Trixie ist aus Toy Story dieser Triceratops oder?
Ja
Der hier
Die Debian-Dinger sind doch immer nach einem Toy-Story-Charakter benannt.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob mein tolles Skript so tut, wie ich mir das hier denke.
Also, Update.
Command not found. Nice.
Upt. Install. LZ4. Skript schon mal fehlgeschlagen.
Update.
Ha!
Nice.
Guck mal, und jetzt habe ich topaktuelle
Debian-Images bei mir rumliegen,
die ich nachts aktualisieren kann.
Genau, Forky.
Wer ist Forky eigentlich bei Toy Story?
Das Viech.
Ich kann mich legit an dieses Viech nicht mehr erinnern.
Ich glaube, denen gehen die Namen langsam aus.
Gab es Andy schon?
Andy?
Aber wenn du den Release-Link mit Stable angibst, bekommst du dann auch den richtigen Release-Link raus.
Ist eine gute Frage.
Äh.
Ja.
Geht auch.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das bei Daily geht.
Siehst du, da geht es nicht.
Da muss man es mit dem Codenamen machen.
Also.
Wir können schon mal was anderes machen.
Wir können mal LZ4 schon mal installieren.
Es werden mir gerade zu viele Fenster, die ich hier am Start habe.
repos.exe boot.wim docker file. lz4 wollen wir installieren. ich gehe einfach mal davon aus
aus dass es auch in user bin lz 4 lz 4
das brauchen wir jetzt nämlich gleich noch bild
dann logge ich mich hier schon mal aus
Jetzt können wir die Debian Images runterladen und gleich entpacken.
Also init-ramefs kannst du halt nichts nachinstallieren.
Das ist so wie es ist.
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung habe, ob man da nicht auch apt installieren könnte
drinne.
Aber es wird wahrscheinlich nicht richtig funktionieren.
so
jetzt können wir uns da wieder per ssh drauf verbinden da sind wir gut also
und schon haben wir top aktuelle debian images sind image lz 4 stable lz 4
ich kenne buzzi nur weil es von morgen einer im stream geschrieben hat im chat ich kannte
das bis heute morgen auch nicht ich könnte ja klar kenne ich das aber erkennt das nicht
ich habe keine ahnung gehabt dass das existiert bis heute morgen gut c aber sogar noch irgendwie
oft glaube ich habe morgen hier mal geguckt aber wusste ich nicht also ich habe noch nicht
sogar hundertprozentig gecheckt, was das eigentlich ist.
So, jetzt haben wir hier unsere
Debian-Images. Jetzt müssen wir mal
weiterbauen an unserem Skript.
Ah, Mist!
Curl und V-Gate brauche ich noch, hä?
Na, Curl reicht.
Curl brauche ich noch.
Okay, kann ich gleich nochmal
die Datei bilden.
Sehr, sehr schlau.
Ähm, Wim?
copy files curl curl brauchen wir noch und dann muss auch noch in stocker file curl
was versprecht ihr euch denn von der umstellung auf boot c vielleicht kriege ich da ein bisschen
bisschen besser raus was das eigentlich genau ist und macht und tut
ok also wo ich noch mal guten
install
Okay, haben wir Curl jetzt drauf?
Ja.
LZ4 ist auch drauf.
Das ist ja deutsches Tastatur...
Englisches Tastatur-Layout.
Wie macht man denn der Init-RAM-FS denn ein deutsches Tastatur-Layout?
Init-RAM-FS, Debian...
ähm, change keyboard layout.
Komm.
Wir vibe-adminen heute.
Got it. You want to change the keyboard?
Init RAMFS shell. Edit console.
Was?
Debian stores the keyboard layout
eine drama fs in etc in tram fs tools in der drama fs ist das so etc in der drama fs konf
ja kommen wisse
jetzt muss ich jetzt muss ich
ich nur noch dafür sorgen
etc default
ich muss kurz lesen anstatt dass du jetzt ein de-ball-image hättest du ein bootable
container als image also ein OCI-Imageformat mit kernel dass man bootet so auf ganze aha
Leicht der Fallback, du hast ein Image mit Tag, das in den...
Aha.
Da muss ich ja mal Gedanken drüber machen, ob mir das gefällt oder nicht.
XKB-Layout.
Okay.
Also, wie machen wir das jetzt schön hier mit...
Wir replacen einfach usdurch.de, oder?
Das sollte doch am einfachsten sein.
Cat, seht.
usdurch.de
Chat, warum bin ich zu dumm für Seed gerade?
Was mache ich falsch?
Ist doch so richtig.
Nee, nicht minus i.
Hä?
Bin ich jetzt...
ach es habe ich vergessen ja ihr habt recht ihr habt recht ihr habt recht
der seht minus etc default keyboard so das muss man editieren und danach
etc in it etc in ramfs tools in ramfs keymap
keymap n steht da standardmäßig trainer im mpn
seht
ihm abend durch kino bs ersetzen
genau so diese zwei sachen brauchen wir also machen wir noch raus diese zwei sachen müssen
noch einbauen etc in ram fs in der tram dass da seht also einmal das hier brauchen war und
das hier brauchen wir die zwei sachen ob es jetzt habe ich
gehen wir in unser in unser docker fall ran ran
die zwei dinger brauchen wir brauchen wir noch irgendwas lz 4 curl zeug haben
schon kopiert nur ich glaube das ist so
ist er was ist ja was als man irgendwas editieren muss mit diesem ding ist wir
einfach deutlich angenehmer wo liegt wohl liegt denn wir eigentlich ab install
will in welchem verzeichnis liegt mir danach auch user user user bin user bin
okay ich gehe noch ein bisschen installiert
ok bild
so und dann haben wir aber alles was wir brauchen da können wir uns uns kommt widmen
So, zack, Reboot.
Install.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir jetzt einen Wim haben.
Wir haben einen Wim.
Der hat Probleme, der Wim.
Aber er öffnet, ja, okay, immerhin.
Und wir haben deutsche Keymap, Leute.
hat funktioniert deutsche team
denkt ein aktuell best practice ist container fall einstatt das altbekannte
juckt mich überhaupt nicht ich brauche das zum bilden von parker sachen ob das
jetzt ein docker pfeile sondern container falle ja vollkommen egal
ich benutze das image ähnlich was da rauskommt so jetzt kann man unserem
skript weiterbauen also hier unten connecten wir uns wieder auf den installer wir machen das anders
wir gehen hier hin und connecten wird auf den installer also skript wie habe ich es genannt
bin ja falsch hier install install punkt sh also ok chat wie geht es weiter jetzt haben wir hier
uns die disk ausgewählt nachdem wir die disk ausgewählt haben wohin das installieren wollen
müssen wir jetzt das image runterladen also curl wir machen hier oben man auch nur variable server
server ip gleich 1 2 1 6 8.2.55
wenn jetzt einfach server so curl minus s wir wollen nicht zugesperrt werden http doppelpunkt
doppel slash prozent dollar server slash wie habe ich das genannt install image slash
debian minus jetzt distro punkt image punkt lz 4
so
ich glaube so
ab ev hätte ich noch gerne das haben wir auch noch drauf hat dabei sind pv hätte ich noch
gerne install pv dass wir eine progress bar anzeigen lassen können in der shell
copy files pv
ja das muss man einmal initial machen danach kann dieses installer image immer gleich bleiben
booten kann er schon mal
Ups, habe ich es irgendwie kaputt gemacht? Ich habe es zerstört. Neu booten. So, install.
ok jetzt kann man sie unten wieder connecten da sind wir wieder also nicht immer falsch da
müssen wir hin also köln minus s ok wir pv das jetzt und dann nach der f0 einfach mal gucken
ob das funktioniert was ich jetzt gebastelt habe also setup wir wollen debian stable wir
wollen sie auf diese disque installieren und und und es downloadet es downloadet das image
gut jetzt müssen wir das ganze noch jetzt müssen wir das ganze noch dekompressen
das war hier davor lz 4- d ist es glaube ich wenn ich nicht ganz falsch schlägt pv ja okay
noch mal gucken stable disk sehr schön das flutscht das flutscht auch richtig da seht
ihr mal guck mal ich downloade das image jetzt mit 664 mb obwohl es gar nicht stimmt
ich downloade das ja über eine gigabit connection das ist weil lz 4 halt so schnell die compressed
ich lade das runter mit 100 mb die sekunde aber durch das die kompressen kommt darauf
664 deswegen habe ich mir gedacht es eine gute idee dass lz 4 zu kompressen
ok alles klar dann obst dann testen wir mal was jetzt passiert wenn man sagen die idee
ist die idee überhaupt dabei ja glücklicherweise die idee nach
nach disc
die idee nach disk block sei es gleich 4m
kannst du zwei pv anzeigen lassen was meinst du
meinst zwei disks wenn es mehr als eine disk gibt in dem server
das geht denn der nimmt alles was vom typ disk ist und lässt mich das auswählen
Achso, zwei Progress Bars.
Ja, aber...
Ja, bestimmt irgendwie, aber dass man jetzt zu kompliziert
würde für die Geschichte.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob es funktioniert.
Also...
Äh, E ist Extended. Das ist das gleiche wie
E-Crap, quasi.
Regex. Extended Regex.
Ich bin mir übrigens
gar nicht sicher, ob ich das brauche
hier davor.
so also jetzt kommt es hier jetzt kommt der moment der wahrheit leute so ganz fertig ist
das immer noch nicht aus name selection könnten wir theoretisch auch noch machen
haus nehmen sie nicht wir müssen auch noch gucken wie man da cloud in it rein kriegen
aber jetzt jetzt sollte er zumindest schon mal was installieren also passt mal auf ich
Ich sag Install Debian Stable auf diese Disk.
Bam.
Äh, Chat.
Irgendwie ist es kaputt gerade.
Buggt mein Engine X rum?
Systemzene restart Engine X.
nochmal. Zack. Stable. Disk.
Okay.
Hat schon funktioniert. Der NGINX hat ja irgendwelche Schmerzen.
So, jetzt ist installiert.
Reboot. Ach, Reboot
funzt, oder was?
Ähm.
Okay, wenn
Reboot nichts nicht funzt, passt mal auf.
Echo, B,
rock sus rq träger das bauen wir noch moment das brauchen wir noch ins skript
ein das war noch ins skript ein ich denke es heißt setup das heißt doch gar
nicht das heißt install install.sh
echo b also wenn ihr mal eine lösungskiste habt ihr nicht mehr partur
booten will das hier geht immer ihr müsst nach sus pk pippen das ist hart hat vor reboot
wir machen mal noch was anderes wir machen hier nach mann ins sink dann machen wir den echo
install
install completed, now rebooting
sleep 5 machen wir mal oder sleep 3
wir machen extra wir machen extra einen sync davor dass ja auch alles auf die platte raus
geflasht hat.
Okay.
Dann gehen wir mal hier raus
und tun mal so, als sind wir hier drauf.
Zack. S.
Debian Stable auf diese Disk.
Bam. Volle Pulle drauf.
Sag mal, was hat denn der für Schmerzen?
Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das hier?
Das liegt an VMware, Leute.
Das liegt jetzt an VMware.
Wir machen mal was anderes. Zack.
Power off. Bam.
Aber mit Power-Off geht nicht mal.
The fuck?
By the way, warum ist das jetzt auf einmal im Fullscreen?
Äh.
Ah, Moment, Moment.
Das ist mein Debian, was da schon startet.
Ich will doch gar nicht, dass mein Debian startet.
Aha.
Aber der Install hat funktioniert.
Nochmal.
Nochmal kurz hier booten.
Wir wissen, ob das alles klappt.
install es stable auf die disk
was ist das denn
habe ich da irgendwie den snapshot oder so dass es rumspackt
es liegt 100 pro an vmware ich sag's euch also vor allem war krepp
mein raspberry pi sollte nicht ausgelastet sein von 4 mb die sekunde
der langweilig der juckt das juckt den überhaupt nicht
durch das man da ist irgendwas das ist irgendeine vmware geschichte ich sag's euch
irgendein vmware mist kann er den 2 nx neu starten okay wir installieren jetzt
einfach debian testing okay vielleicht geht das besser ich sind das was ist da kaputt
ich wette das sind vmware probleme das sind 100 pro vmware probleme
Jetzt mag er anscheinend wieder.
Installation completed.
Now rebooting.
Zack.
Und wir haben unser Debian, Leute.
Installiert.
Ist das nicht nice?
Wir haben keinen User oder sonst was.
Aber wir haben ein vollständiges Debian installiert.
Der kommt mit dem Download und gleichzeitig dem Decompressen nicht.
Klar.
Das ist eine fette Kiste hier.
schon einmal unser demian installiert
wobei das alleine ja noch nicht reichen
so einfach ist es nicht
also mal jetzt folgendes wir noch mal gehen hier rein
so mein installer ist ja alles okay install da müssen wir nichts mehr dran machen an dem
installer image selbst
jetzt war man ein snapshot dass ich immer wieder schnell dahin zurück kann
kannst du dir datei nicht zuerst runterladen und dann lz 4 entpacken
jetzt noch egal.
Ist das Pipe? Pipe?
Oh, oh, oh, was hat er jetzt?
Leute, es ist kaputt.
Es ist kaputt gegangen beim Snapshot machen.
WTF?
Alter,
Vmware, was ist das wieder für ein Schrott?
Vmware ist wieder richtig räudig
hier am Start.
was ein mist noch mal probieren ich will dann statt wenn man lass mich scheiß ding booten
classic pro kommer
snapshot
so ich hoffe es hat es funktioniert ja funzt okay sehr gut
jetzt hat snapshot machen funktioniert also weiter im text install punkt sh was
brauchen wir dann noch also lass mal überlegen wir dauern das image wie die
den das image auf die disk
Ich kann mich schlecht konzentrieren.
Wir haben heute so viel gemacht schon.
Heute war echt sehr produktiver Stream, oder?
Muss man echt sagen.
Exzellent.
naja alfred ich habe im vorfeld schon ein bisschen geguckt also ist ja egal
dass ich jetzt ganz planlos daran gegangen bin so laut innen wird eklig
das weiß ich jetzt schon cloud winnet cloud innen wird hardcore abfacke wie
bei den koch sendungen früher ich habe da was vorbereitet okay wir müssen uns auf jeden fall
das image mountain so viel ist sicher wir müssen jetzt an dem installierten debian was machen also
wir können das jetzt wir sind bis jetzt wir machen uns ein verzeichnis und wir mountain das okay wie
machen wir wie mountain wir denn jetzt am besten mount also mk die mnt machen wir dann sagen wir
war mount dev sda 1 wahrscheinlich nach mnt failed warum fehlt mount in busy box
chat gpt chat gpt so am labern alter in valley is busy box in it is a classic
jet gpt schwätzt wieder an
maunz minus tx4 maunz minus tx4 excellent das muss ich mir auf das muss hier rein mount x4
allerdings nicht der fsda 1 sondern dollar disc
1 also quasi
so
so und die musik ist fertig die muss man kurz anschmeißen wieder
so wird die das gemeldet alles klar den reboot den auskommen kommentiere ich mal aus weil ich
will jetzt nicht guten so hat aber das gemacht jetzt gehen wir nach slash mnt
cloud in it wie macht man cloud in it und die config in das debian einbau normalerweise macht
man cloud in it über einen über ein zweites laufwerk an der vm mit cloud in it zeug drauf
wie macht man cloud in it aus der vm raus jetzt habe ich mir jetzt so einfach vorgestellt aber
ich weiß gar nicht wie das geht
irgendjemand erfahrung da auch schon also cloud in den wirtschaft benutzen um
sachen zu konfigurieren
Was haltet ihr davon, wenn wir noch den Hostname
äh, setzbar machen?
Hilft das?
Ne, das hilft nicht, weil ich jetzt nicht über Proxmox mache.
Disk USB beim Start einbinden?
Ich hab ja nix zum Einbinden.
Ich bote über PXE
und das soll dann am Ende raus...
Okay, wie macht man lokales Cloud-Init?
aber hier wie kann ich cloud in meinem image bacon
du jetzt ist dort im konzert ist so dass es beim ersten boot seine dateien von
jeweiligen cloud zieht aha cloud ist nicht das user fest einzubrennen sondern
ja blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla
was ist das beispiel low-clou was etc etc cloud chat meinte des
verzeichnis gibt's oder chat gpt hallo ziehe ich das zusammen etc cloud cloud
CFG D90 Data Source CFG.
Hello.
What?
Cloud in it, no cloud.
etc cloud cloud cfg die sieht man kann das ist ja nice man kann sich die
configs dann über http laden das ja perfekt dann zieht er die
configs wie allen anderen krempel von vom web server
ja das ist top dass das brahma das ist exzellent
also dann machen wir hier mal jetzt der datei in meinem auf
meinem web server hier auch hinter ins install image oder so
ja keine ahnung data oder 99 haste punkt cfg so wirst du sag muss man da oben was
reinschreiben was war da muss man da irgendwie cloud config oder so reinschreiben vielleicht
wobei ich mache mal ich mache man ordner dass das das konfix heißt wir schreiben da oben mal
hier rein cloud konflikt über die sich ob man das braucht data source muss dann in dem fall
sein 12 16 82.55 slash configs dann mkdir configs ja fast richtig mkdir configs install image 99
nach Configs.
So.
Wie bindet man das jetzt
gescheit ein?
Wieder über mein...
Okay, wo muss ich denn hin?
etc cloud
cloud cfg
d
Da muss das hin.
Heißt?
Heißt, wir machen da jetzt einen Curl
oder was also weg ok ok das muss man an mount mnt das muss ich mal ausprobieren dass wir das
hinkriegen war war ich kann kann schon immer tippen war www html so und da gibt es jetzt
install punkt sh so also wir installieren hier unseren kram dann monte ich mir den kram okay
Dann gehen wir nach mnt slash etc slash cloud slash cloud cfgd, ne?
Slash, ne, das war's.
Okay, dann curlen wir.
Curl.
http://server slash configs slash 99 custom.cfg
nach 99
custom.cfg
So, jetzt haben wir dann eine Datei.
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt soweit funzt,
was ich hier gemacht habe.
Also, install.
Äh.
Hallo?
Vor allem, wer macht wieder komische Sachen?
Was fehlt noch?
MKD-P?
Wieso?
Wo denn?
Ne, ne.
Das ist da.
Wir gucken mal hier mal, wenn das rumbackt.
Ansonsten.
Okay, irgendwie ist es.
Also vor allem, wer fuckt schon gerade ein bisschen ab?
ok stable disk jetzt guck mal jetzt geht es komischerweise wieder schnell mit dem
installen keine ahnung was voran treibt was jetzt hallo
Hey Mann, VmWare, was ist dein Problem, Alter?
Meine Güte.
Was ist denn für Schmerzen?
Das ist eine ungeheurige VmWare-Geschichte.
Stable Disk, bam.
der snapshot ist das problem du rebootest nicht lügt nicht so cd mnt ls etc cloud cloud cfg punkt
D.
Und da ist eine 99 Custom
CFG.
Okay. Gut.
Dann schauen wir mal kurz.
Ah, jetzt habe ich eine Idee.
Jetzt gucken wir mal kurz in meine
...
NGINX
Logs, tail-f
var log
NGINX access log
Da müsste es jetzt ja gleich Anfragen
geben, wenn das Ding rebootet.
Ich mach den Snapshot weg.
Irgendwie spackt vor allem wer mit dem Snapshot rum.
Wenn ich jetzt reboote und das Debian startet, dann müsste der eigentlich...
Das geht natürlich wieder nicht.
Dann müsste der jetzt eigentlich versuchen, sich Sachen zu ziehen vom Server, oder?
Ja.
macht irgendwas hier nix ok der download funktioniert nicht habe ich irgendwas
verkehrt gemacht habe ich den server falsch geschrieben install punkt sh
Seht ihr irgendwas Falsches?
Custom CFG.
X99 Custom CFG.
HTTPS!
Alter, oh man!
Lul.
So, tail-f access-log.
disk install complete in augen das stimmt überhaupt nicht dass du
genau reboot ist. Ich reboot
jetzt.
Reset.
Okay, jetzt schauen wir mal.
Der bootet jetzt.
Jetzt ist er gleich
bei der Netzwerkkarte.
Ha! Es geht! Es geht!
Der zieht sich Cloud-Config
über das Netzwerk.
Also die es nicht gibt, aber die können wir jetzt anlegen.
ok moment wo er nicht holen wir mal network config war um fuck was gibt es sonst noch
network config metadata sonst noch mehr vielleicht okay jetzt muss ich mal kurz in
mein geht lab gucken er gibt es nicht gibt gibt gucken wir haben doch hier network config
also cd configs network config
was macht eine sehr wichtige sache das hat den interface namen wieder auf etha 0 weil
ich krieg anfälle wenn das ding ns 85 1580 xd hd heißt und dann machen wir die hcp sehr schön da
müssen wir das ganze noch mal machen ich habe die idee wir können snapshot ist das mit dem
gutnäglich.
So, wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt
einen Snapshot.
Und zwar
einen Snapshot,
wenn wir hier sind, okay?
Das müsste doch jetzt funktionieren.
Snapshot.
Vmware, please!
Warum ist die Software
so scheiße geworden?
Chat!
Warum ist diesen Software so kacke?
Mittlerweile
Das war früher beste
Ah jetzt geht es vor allem mal
Okay
Hyper-V
Ganz bestimmt ist Hyper-V beste
Es kommt als nächstes Xen Server oder was?
Okay
So, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob der die
Also so schnell konnte ich jetzt nicht gucken, Chat.
Hat er sich jetzt was gezogen?
Ne, der hat sich... Hä?
Bin ich jetzt total dumm?
Eben hat er sich die Custom-CFG gezogen.
Aber jetzt hat er beim Booten nichts gemacht.
Wie kann denn das sein?
Der macht überhaupt keine Netzwerkkonfiguration.
der macht überhaupt keine netzwerk konflikt mehr als das paint
Ich will hier einen Snapshot machen.
VmW. Hier. Genau hier.
Aber VmW will nicht.
VmW hat einfach keinen Bock da drauf.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Vielleicht hat VmW jetzt doch Bock drauf.
Aber was hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen gehabt?
Hat er die Datei da nicht richtig abgelegt?
Oder?
Oh, was?
Vm-Ware, was ist dein Problem, Mann?
Die Software ist ja mal unbenutzbar
Scheiße geworden, seit Prodcom
den Kram übernommen hat.
Das kann doch jetzt nicht alles den hier in Ernst sein.
Guckt euch das an!
Was ist denn das?
Mit Snapshots geht's nicht mehr.
Die neueste hier, 25 Ink-Dabbers.
Gibt's da was Neues vielleicht?
Äh.
Ich sollte wieder meine 18er-Version benutzen und Ruhe geben.
Aber dann muss man diese Windows-Security-Sachen ausschalten.
Okay, muss ich vielleicht
den alten Snapshot löschen.
Geht's vielleicht.
Das könnte so easy sein,
wenn vor allem, wenn ich so rumsacken würde.
Now rebooting.
Du rebootest überhaupt nicht.
MNT, ETC, Cloud.
Cloud cfg.de 99 custom
Ok passt ich glaube ich sollte an mountain und sünden dann geht es vielleicht auch
Jetzt funzt es jetzt
Jetzt ruft er sich Dinger hier ab.
Guck hier, Metadata versucht er sich abzurufen.
Aber da hat sich auch so, da hat sich Netzwerk-Config und so hat er sich auch abgerufen.
Okay, also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall was, was Metadata heißt.
Da wüsste ich aber gar nicht, was wir da reinpacken sollen.
Einfach Metadata.
Wurst Hypervisor of all time, ja.
Auch weil, da gibt es bestimmt noch was Schlimmeres.
Cloud Config.
Lassen wir einfach leer.
Okay, was habe ich denn hier noch für Files?
Zeig mal her.
Ich habe hier eine Network Config.
Ich habe User Data.
Da muss der ganze Campbell rein später.
und dann habe ich noch Vendor Data.
Braucht man das vielleicht auch noch?
CP, Metadata, Vendor Data.
Metadata habe ich hier gar nicht.
User Data.
Okay.
Jetzt sollte er zumindest so weit passen,
dass der alles abrufen kann.
Gucken wir nochmal.
Snapshot.
Restore.
Bam.
wie ein snapshot solche bugs wo ich habe keine ahnung weil vor allem was sagt
mittlerweile stable disk wir machen noch was anderes
wir sind ja hier mittlerweile ganz gut dabei install punkt sh wir machen hier
den SYNC und den Unmount.
Unmount brauchen wir hier auf jeden Fall noch.
Äh.
CD.
Oder irgendwie so.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Wir wechseln jetzt wieder. Wechseln jetzt
wieder zurück.
Machen wir hier.
Ganz zum Schluss.
Wechseln wir wieder zurück.
sagen noch mal sinkt aber hier unten war noch mal sinkt und dann sagen wir sie kriegt eine
sekunde zeit was war eigentlich plötzlich ist aber da sagen wir an mount slash mnt und sagen
noch mal so meinetwegen dann machen wir uns diese meldung und dann rieb guten wir okay so gut
snapshot sagt jetzt
also stable disk
aber ihr seht es in einer team wird mein gott nicht schon wieder und ich schaue
wieder vor mwf ich drehe ich drehe durch wie soll man diesen kram verwenden wie
soll man das verwenden das ist ja unbenutzbar
ok install completed rebooting und während der boot sekunde sekunde sekunde ich muss hier mit
gucken was der abruft echte gangster kummer er benennt sogar in ethan olob hat das gesehen
der ruf network config am metadata user data und wenn nur data perfekt perfekt
user data brauchen wir jetzt müssen ein bisschen was einrichten user data also in user data
ich kann mal kopie ich kann ein paar sachen kopieren die ich ja ich habe einmal hier drin
eine disable root das habe ich für irgendwelche anderen cloud kisten verwendet aber es muss ja
hier auch funktionieren so dann haben wir hier drin ssh authorized keys da muss jetzt mein ssh
key rein den hatten wir doch irgendwo gerade cat da hier naja gehen da so vielleicht soll ich mal
fullscreen machen max progress ssh key dann brauchen wir ich weiß nicht mehr wofür ich
das hier habe aber ich mache das einfach mal rein users default und jetzt kommt runcmd da kann man
jetzt kommandos ausführen was wollen wir wollen wir irgendwas ausführen überhaupt ja wollen wir
wir wollen ausführen erste mal ab update das ist nie verkehrt ab update funst was habe ich
denn hier noch drin das habe ich ja schon wieder komplett vergessen als sehr schön passt mal auf
jetzt seht ihr richtige magic falls das funktioniert was hier gebaut habe passt
mal auf das ist richtig sex hat wisst ihr was das hier macht leute ihr werdet gleich sehen
wenn alles funktioniert werde ich es gleich sehen es macht hause mal gucken
ob ich kann ja passt
Jetzt geht's wieder. Jetzt hängt wieder Forever nicht.
Okay. Whatever.
So. Achtung. Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Naja.
Netzwerkstells. Netzwerkstells.
Macht der Update.
Deswegen hängt's jetzt auch ein bisschen.
Haha.
Seht ihr, was das macht?
Für nice Sachen.
Seht ihr das? Das ist richtig Hacker-Man-Five-Head-High-IQ-Shit.
der chat denkt denkt warum fliegt also aus man sieht jetzt beim login die ip-adresse dieses
kiste die kiste gekriegt hat das heißt wenn ich mich jetzt besser sein morgen will nachdem ich
auf die konsole geguckt habe habe ich auch gleich die ip das ist doch extrem die kogger
zatschen silva dankeschön für den sub das heißt wir können jetzt hier sagen ssh
debian muss ich nehmen debian fix ssh
und ich bin per ssh auf meiner neuen cloud kiste die allerdings nicht in der cloud ist sondern nur
ähnlich professioniert wird wie in der Cloud, sondern bei mir
lokal läuft. Ist das nicht nice?
Guck mal, wie einfach jetzt so ein Install
funktioniert.
Okay, nächstes Problem.
Fremder Tools. Fremder Tools
sollten drauf. Das heißt,
da gehen wir wieder in User Data.
Das ist ein massive
Pog, ist das.
So, also Upt, Update.
So, wir installieren jetzt ein paar
Basic Sachen. Upt.
ja apps install so tmux braucht man immer tmux braucht man immer htop braucht man wird wort
brauchen wir dass man gleich gucken können ob wir in vmware sind tree ncdo pv und jq oder sowas
Curl, ja, ist recht. Curl.
We get
NetTools.
Heißt NetTools oder NetTool unter dem?
Ja.
Installed NetTool.
NetTools.
Wisst ihr warum?
Weil ich IfConfigEnjoyer bin.
Kommt da
NetTools drauf.
Ja, wie?
Was ist hier los, Chat?
Was ist daran, Boomer-if-Config zu verwenden?
Chat, Chat, okay, okay, sind wir mal ehrlich.
Okay, sind wir mal ehrlich.
Pass mal auf.
Chat, was ist...
Jetzt mal ehrlich.
Was ist schöner?
If-Config oder IP-Add?
sagt mal, was ist schöner?
IP-Ad, weil es Farben hat.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich...
Ich gebe zu, ganz ehrlich,
mit Farben finde ich IP-Ad
auch besser, weil das highlightet direkt
die IP. Bei F-Config weiß man gleich, wo man
hingucken muss.
Aber ihr habt schon recht.
Mit den Farben... Also, wenn
es Farben hat, IP-Ad,
dann ist IP-Ad tatsächlich
schöner und besser lesbar.
Ja, das stimmt, das muss ich zugeben.
Aber ansonsten,
ifconfig jeden Tag
über IP-Ad.
Achso, ich wollte ja
wird-what installieren und gucken, was da...
wird-what
also das heißt wir wollen jetzt sinngemäß so was hier machen wie wird wort soll da kreppen
wir nach vmware wenn da vmware rauskommt dann sagen wir ab install open vm tools heißt das
glaube ich ob vm tools mal gucken ob das funktioniert was hier gebastelt habe copy
sehr gut exzellent das bauen wir doch schon mal hier
das brauchen wir doch schon mal hier ein also wird wort oder hat der hat garantiert probleme
der hat garantiert probleme mit dem pipe genauso wie hier oben mit dem es kämpfe ich werde das
auch mal das ist halt mit jammel so also wird wort dann machen wir das gleiche noch mal wenn
es kvm ist wenn es kvm ist installieren wir como guest agent was richtig geschrieben west west
agent west agent gibt es sonst noch irgendwas nerviges was ich da haus
name wobei haus nehmen wir gucken wie man das mit haus der machen
etc wie sehen das eigentlich aus okay wir müssen noch was ganz wichtiges
machen. Wim-Maus-Mode muss global disabled werden. Ganz wichtig. Sonst kratze ich ab,
wenn ich das benutze. Instant Death. Wenn Maus-Mode in Wim aktiviert ist.
Ist wirklich Instant-Rip.
Wie schaltet man das am besten aus?
Gibt es sowas wie etc.wimrc oder sowas?
Okay, etc.wimrc.
Ist hier irgendwas editierend drin?
Na, hallo.
Wimrc.local.
Das klingt doch gut.
Wim?
WimRC.local
disable mouse.
Geht das so?
wartet mal wartet mal ich zieht jetzt mal ich zieht jetzt mal wo habe ich das
habe ich das wm rc
im rc
ich finde es nicht hier moment moment was man da in den städten passen auf
probleme habe ich öfters hier das brauchen wir so ja gut dass ich das habe
da wäre ich hier durchgedreht mit dem da und da Escapen.
Brauchen wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Chat, habt ihr noch eine Idee?
Was brauchen wir noch standardmäßig auf jeder Debian-Kiste,
die wir installieren?
Ist da irgendwas Wichtiges noch dabei?
Wim!
Natürlich.
Leute, ich kack noob.
Wim!
Ich lege Wim-Configs an, aber installiere kein Wim.
Ja, das ist ziemlich pepega.
ich glaube das ist okay so wir machen einfach ein sleep 1 runter für whatever falls da noch
ein bisschen braucht immer schon drauf was die qual quatsch hyper wie für linux und sagt bloß
das gibt's ich meine ich würde nicht davon ausgehen dass es das gibt aber aber bei microsoft
Weißt du nie, das gibt Microsoft SQL auch für Linux mittlerweile.
Sag nicht, die wollen wirklich Hyper-V für Linux machen, oder?
Yobu brauchen wir nicht, wir haben Temux drauf.
Hyper-V-Demons gibt es für Linux.
Ja, was soll das denn sein?
Linux
Windows 12 hat dann ein Linux 12
Ja, dann kann er in der Präsentation wenigstens auch
vor Glück weinen wieder, wie bei Windows 11
Dann hat er wenigstens einen Grund
Ach so, wenn die
Ach, das ist so was wie ein Guest Agent
Okay, schauen wir mal, ob das hier funzt, was ich da so gebastelt habe.
Snapshot.
Achso, Hostname brauchen wir.
Erstmal gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Hostname brauchen wir dann auch irgendwie.
Wie setzt man denn am besten den Hostname?
Achso.
Zack, zack.
aus dem CTL. Ja, aber ich bin ja nicht
in das Linux gebootet. Ich muss das irgendwie
über Cloud Init machen.
Und, oh, das wird in der Tat
schwierig. Mein Cloud Init ist
statisch auf dem Server.
Ähm.
Aber mein Hostname muss ins Cloud Init rein.
Kann man ins Cloud Init noch irgendwie
lokale Files inkluden oder sowas?
Ja, ja, aber...
Das...
Die Cloud-Config ist ja auf dem Server.
so also ich brauche ja die cloud config statisch vom server aber dynamisch dann von in der lokalen
datei brauche ich mache ich das jetzt am besten aber jetzt gucken wir gucken wir gucken jetzt
erst einmal ob das was ich hier gebaut habe funktioniert hat ssh fix ssh ist das nicht
geil moment passt mal auf wir machen jetzt noch was anderes ich will mal gucken ob ich
Ich meine, ob ich das noch verbessern kann,
mein Fix-SSH.
Einfach die letzten...
Pass mal auf die letzten Kommandos hier.
SSH. Bam, schlägt fehl.
Fix-SSH.
Shit, geht nicht. Command-Not-Forn.
Äh.
Kann das sein, dass man das so nicht machen darf,
Chat?
Kann das sein, dass das so nicht geht?
Dass man das nicht hier in einem
Skript irgendwie verwenden darf?
Last Last Command.
Geh weg.
Last Command not working.
Mal gucken, ob das hier die AI rauspasen kann, was ich da komisches rein...
Ah, a classic shell!
Was ist FC-LN1, Chat?
Was zum...
Was ist das?
Ach, das letzte Command.
Ewald.
Jawohl.
Aber das letzte Command?
Nee, das ist keine gute Idee.
Das ist keine gute Idee.
Last Command kann auch was anderes sein.
Ne, ne.
Classic Shellgotcher.
Ja, das Chat-GPT weiß halt Bescheid.
Hat das denn jetzt funktioniert?
Haben wir jetzt
Open
OpenVM-Tools drauf?
Install OpenVM-Tools.
Nice, hat funktioniert.
Haben wir denn auch WIMP drauf?
Haben wir. T-Mux haben wir. Jawohl.
tree haben wir auch ja ja von sehr schön und und wim und wim ist wim maus
disabled wim ist maus disabled excellent beste beste system so wie machen wir das
jetzt mit dem hausnamen am besten kann man in cloud init lokale dateien
inkluden irgendwie also dass ich quasi sagen kann so was hier sinngemäß dass
ich sagen kann in klub keine ahnung temp blub so was und dass er sich daran was
geht das geht das laut in it in clube files
include
ich hätte heute open code verwenden können für einige sachen aber open code
ist der meinung die models die die ganze zeit früh waren sind nicht mehr free
ziemlich selten
ich glaube aus dem kannst du nicht mehr
cloud config setzen
ja das problem ist meine cloud config
kommt statisch vom server und den
hausnamen der ist ja dynamisch gesetzt
ich müsste den lokal ich müsste noch ein
zusätzliches cloud in den fall irgendwie da inkluden können was haben wir denn
hier kommt man hier in cloud file in klug
aha kann ich dann
ja gerne 4.7 ist echt übel
Ich habe vorhin kurz überlegt, mir einen Mac zu kaufen für lokale AI-Stells.
Aber da habe ich festgestellt, die, wo sich lohnt, die Models, die halt richtig groß sind, wo mir dann auch die Grafikkarte nichts bringt, das ist dann auch richtig teuer.
Also werde ich es doch nicht machen.
Okay, Chat. Also, wir probieren das jetzt mal aus.
Ob das funzt. Also, wir gehen jetzt mal hier hin.
Wo bin ich denn hier überhaupt gerade? Achso, auf der Kiste.
Also.
Guck dir mal an.
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen. Warte mal.
User Data. Ich kopiere das mal um nach keinerlei Config oder so.
Dann löschen wir UserData und schreiben das rein, wie hier aus dem Beispiel.
Include.
So, nur dass wir bei dem Include reinschreiben.
http://config.
Und dann, und das ist jetzt die Frage, ob das funktioniert.
Und dann, keine Ahnung, root init hostname.
Das ist jetzt die Frage, ob das so funktioniert.
Kann man lokal, kann man auf lokal, oder vielleicht, vielleicht muss man auch so machen.
Eventuell muss man auch so machen.
Oder es geht gar nicht.
Moment, wir fragen mal, ich vibe, ich vibe code mal.
geht das in einer Cloud
Init User Data.
das geht so nicht weil wir den klub nicht unterstützt der grund was
wenn du etwas lokales einlesen willst macht das zum beispiel so war ja als
white files rand cmd das ist ja aber irgendwie schon nicht so geil
Vielleicht lügt vielleicht lügt chat gpt auch und es geht trotzdem
probier mal probier mal das mal aus also in klub passt konfig ist der ganze mist hier drin
So, und jetzt müssen wir noch
Jetzt müssen wir hier noch in unserem Installer
Install.sh
Hä?
Ach, ich hab CD gemacht, ich Depp.
Deswegen hat das nicht autocompleted.
So, jetzt können wir noch in unserem Installer sagen
was wollte ich machen war mein brain funks schon einmal richtig nach drei stunden pxe
also die datei anlegen hier also machen wir mal so was wie hier mal uns also mal echo echo
host nehmen wir müssen wir müssen so was hier machen warte mal echo minus cloud machen wir
hier allerdings laut config also wahrscheinlich müsste man das so machen denke ich mal
denke ich mal so was hier cloud config neue zeile host name doppelpunkt kecke
moin rust keckel backslash n ja und das ganze jetzt nach mnt slash root slash init hostname
ok so
tale auf die access logs
spannend ob das funzt jetzt bin ich mal weil wenn man jetzt so den haus namen setzen können
dann bin ich komplett bin ich komplett zufrieden damit label zack kopieren
war please nicht abkacken wieder please vor allem erfolgen wenn ich abkacken ich
habe kacken heißt nicht abgekackt excellent so hat es bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
Das kann...
Chat...
Nee, Chat-GPT, das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich kann man nur von...
Da müssen wir mal gucken, ob man vielleicht nach etc.cloud-config irgendwas...
Also in diese Cloud-CFG was...
Keckel!
Es heißt Keckel!
Chat!
Es funktioniert!
Easy!
Easy.
easy easy wir können so den hausnamen setzen
der pock sehr extrem jetzt müssen wir uns nur noch überlegen wie wir das hier
in unserem skript einbauen was man auf install punkt sh die machen
gescheiten fzf prompt erst mal gucken ok chat mal kurz feifert feifert brainstorming wie generiert
man in der bash eine kurze uuid uuid und video id in bash uuid gern was ist das denn proxys
kernel random juju das gibt wirklich
habe ich noch nie gesehen dass es gibt das ist mir komplett neue alternativ
könnte man auch sagen, Cat,
Dev,
U-Random,
U-Random, MD5-Sum,
ne, ne, ne, ne, äh, äh, äh,
äh, Dings, ähm, äh,
keine Ahnung, äh,
Head,
8, 8 Charakter, MD5-Sum,
so, das wird, das wird, das würde auch funktionieren,
dann nochmal Head, minus C8, so,
aber keine Ahnung,
die ersten 128
Randoms gehashed, das finde ich
fast besser, das finde ich fast besser,
Wir brauchen irgendeinen Random-Host-Namen.
Was ist das für ein Classic-Hero-ID?
Oh, dieses Geschwärze von
Chat-GPT. Ja, das ist
gut. Das gefällt mir.
Ich hoffe, Head und
sowas ist bei Busybox dabei.
Moment, Chat. Ist MD5-Sum
dabei?
Ist MD5-Sum
in der Busybox?
MD5, ah, MD5 ist dabei.
Excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent, excellent.
PXE bringt dich zum Durchdrehen im Kopf, aber komplett.
Fix SSH, gut, dass ich das hab.
es funzt sehr nice install punkt sh also was machen wir denn jetzt also
wir waren sie ausnahmen der hausnahme soll er nicht heckl sein
der hausname soll sowas wie neben gleich so dass da und dann in debian davor so
So, Debian.
Dollar.
Sowas. Das soll mein Hostname sein.
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch irgendeinen Dialog.
Oder irgendwas.
Ah, oh, was ist das?
WTF?
So.
Lass mal kurz checken, ob das funzt, was ich hier gebaut hab.
Äh.
Warum funzt es nicht?
Chat.
Ach, weil ich Dollar Debian geschrieben hab.
Ich kack Noob, Alter.
Kein Wunder, dass es nicht funzt.
Ja.
Exquisite.
die bianek das ist ein schöner default hausnahme so und jetzt hätte ich gerne
so einen so einen dialog mit fzf zum beispiel
also die die sachen die ich heute gemacht ich muss unbedingt mal was bei
die Pile danach Backup, nicht, dass ich das wieder lösche.
So, also, jetzt.
Name.
So, und jetzt will ich so ein
FZF-Dialog haben, also mal
Echo.
Echo Dollar Name.
So.
Das pipen
wir
nach FZF.
So, und jetzt will ich so was haben wie
Press Enter, bla bla bla.
Auch nochmal.
Halb 5.
So, und jetzt will ich sowas haben.
Press Enter.
Gibt es FZF
Ask
oder Prompt oder sowas.
Kommt wir vibe adminnen heute
Ok minus minus prompt pointer marker
Prompt minus minus prompt gleich
Peckel.
Ah, ja.
So, das ist nice.
Okay, dann schreiben wir jetzt dahin
sowas wie Enter Hostname
or
Press Enter to keep
the generated.
Classic FZF
Problem.
Keep
generated.
Ja, sehr
schön.
Sehr gut.
Und wenn ich jetzt einen Hausname entere,
was passiert dann?
Ah, nix.
Oh.
fcf always print input
print query ob es das gibt
das ist das was ich meine man wird halt einfach viel effektiver weil man ein bisschen
AI-Kram benutzt. Das wird uns alle
nicht ablösen, aber man kommt
dann einfach schneller drauf. Früher hat man
drei Stunden Stack Overflow gegoogelt dafür.
Okay.
Kunst. Okay, ich will
immer... Moment, Moment,
Moment.
Moment, so ganz so ausgereift
ist das doch nicht, was ich hier
gebastelt hab.
wenn ich was eingebe und das match dann drauf dann will ich ja nicht dass das obere ausgewählt
okay ich habe eine idee wir peiten das nach xx und danach awk microcontroller forum hör mal
auf ok db ja und jetzt kommt die raus excellent so das brauchen wir hier das kommt ins skript
install punkt sh das heißt hier haben wir den kram mit dem hausamt die wir nehmen so
name echo name fzf ich hoffe xx ist dabei bei pussy box aber ich denke mal schon awk 1
ok moment
ich muss das irgendwie speichern also quasi wo hier zack zack
prompt mama single quotes ich mache um sowas immer gerne kurz was an input input gleich so
da muss jetzt aber hier drumherum dollar input ich brauche quasi ein bisschen einen eigenen
installer nur dass deutlich schneller geht input ok ok dann kommen wir jetzt
hier noch ausgeben echo minus
einfach mal echo ich sonst was aus
echo disk ausnehmen dollar input
werbung einbauen ja klar das kommt gleich als nächstes dann mache ich auf stream
So, ich würde sagen, unser Installer ist fertig.
Probieren wir das mal aus.
Gehen wir mal hier hin.
Wir können es auch per SSH machen, aber wir gehen mal hin.
So, Install.
Wir wollen Debian Unstable.
Wir wollen es auf SDA installieren.
Hey, achso, ja, okay, der dumpt jetzt erstmal.
Äh, Chat?
Warum fragt er mich nicht nach meinem Hausnamen?
Wo?
Was jetzt?
Was ist das Problem?
Bin ich jetzt blind und check's nicht, was ich falsch gemacht habe?
Da ist FZF drauf, klar.
Ja, trotzdem schön, dass du da bist.
Was hat er denn für Probleme?
Warum geht das jetzt nicht?
Ja.
Hä?
Okay, Chad, wo steigt der denn jetzt hier aus?
Mountain funktioniert noch.
Hä?
Wo ist denn jetzt mein Denkfehler hier?
Ich sehe überhaupt nicht, wo der...
Hat das andere noch funktioniert?
X-Arcs? Doch, ist auch da.
der view random ist auch da okay
ich kann es ja lokal ausführen
Aber das Minus...
Wir machen das hier oben einfach mal weg gerade.
Das funzt.
Also das kackt vorher aus irgendwelchen Gründen ab.
aber ich weiß nicht warum also es liegt an diesem set zeug ja also das prinzip
herr also irgendwelche
Um und mt
Also wir machen das jetzt noch mal hier dann komme ich dir also irgendwelche sachen
Gucken wir mal also wir machen jetzt mehr echo debugging 1
So weit so weit kommt er nicht 12
Echo 3.
So.
Ah ja.
Alles gut.
Hier kackt er ab, Boy.
Hier kackt er ab.
But why?
Was?
Chat.
Hä?
Alter, wo ist das Problem?
Nehmen wir sonst die UID Variante
Meint ihr da kackt er nicht ab?
Also äh
Cut
Def
Was war das?
U U U ID
Ähm
Head
Minus C8
Gucken ob das funktioniert
Oh Mann.
So.
Mein Snapshot ist wahrscheinlich schon 500 Billionen
Gigabyte
Das funzt
Ey, warum funzt
Das und das andere nicht
Muss man das in irgendeiner Art und Weise verstehen
Naja, anscheinend nicht, egal
Kann man auch nehmen, ist auch gut, passt
Alles, okay
Okay, gut.
Dann halt nicht.
Wenn er nicht mag, dann nicht.
So.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Dann haben wir unser Installer-Skript
fertig.
Dann würde ich sagen, booten wir noch mal
abschließend.
Hier, zack.
Ah, wir müssen noch testen, ob der
mit wie auch guten kann gleich install
er bootet in meinen installer dann sage ich einfach erst stable disk
wobei ein verbesserungs ich spreche mal ab ein verbesserungs vorschlag habe ich
tatsächlich noch ihr install wenn ihr noch welche habt immer her damit wir
haben hier noch wir machen das hier wir machen das am anfang die abfrage machen das so machen
das direkt hier danach selekte disk elektrisch nehmen wir machen das hier direkt danach setzen
es dann da unten ein das ist besser stable installiert sit sd a haus name and the house
name press enter to keep the generated enter selected haus nehmen cloud image wird gedammt
drei sekunden wird gerieh bietet euch das nice ist das nice das ist doch ohne mist das ist auch
nicht in innen wenn es bei einem cloud anbieter installiert ist auch nicht langsamer schneller
wir sind auch nicht langsamer das dauert ungefähr genauso lang weil die mann unter der haube machen
ja was ähnliches und da sind wir ist das nicht nice das ist doch richtig rock alter das mut das
ich muss unbedingt und debian ich muss unbedingt einen backup machen von dem kram und jetzt haben
unsere debian kiste ist ganz ganz zackig wie man das aufbauen kann
so jetzt schalten wir noch mal aus
gucken wir ob das ganze auch mit uefi funktioniert wie gut network ich lösche
schon mal ich lösche schon mal meinen snapshot hat hier 3 8000 sachen gemacht
da sind wir install
also das gefällt mir noch nicht ganz dass der hier dass der hier nichts
schreibt ja dass man hier erstmal enter drücken muss aber an sich chat jetzt mal
ohne scheiß was sagt ihr das ist das ist doch also da steht jetzt irgendwie
klicken in der cloud zweimal auf weiter und haben eine kiste für lokal
eigentliche mix nach das ist schon pock
warum machst du dir so kompliziert am beispiel an der stelle read input an
stelle vom kryptischen query
keine ahnung kann man kann man bei readinput kann man da so eine so eine default angeben
denkt wir sind in so einer busy box es hat nicht in bash guck und schon haben wir eine
kiste ich lasse es jetzt so
außen minus i und dann
excellent komm wir sind auf vorkies it
ist excellent wie es gefällt mich gut okay wir probieren jetzt aber trotzdem noch mal
eine sache aus also in der halben stunde gehe ich was futtern so lange probieren
es noch mal was wir gehen hier noch mal rein wir haben noch unser docker file mit dem ganzen
krempe drin ach so chat wie sieht's aus soll ich den kram pushen auf geht habe
wir müssen auf jeden fall geht nicht nur machen gut
das gefällt wahrscheinlich nicht nur mir so wobei ich habe ja nicht mal alles
hier in dem ordner trainer muss ich eigentlich noch alles ziehen ich müsste
das noch okay das muss ich auch vorbereiten den kameraden rüber kopieren noch vom server wieder
also wir machen noch mal folgendes gibt es die möglichkeit dass man auf eine shell getropft wird
und custom script aus wird da muss ich mal hier fragen ich will auf auf eine shell getropft werden
mit einem in den kram fs ok ok drop shell
linux ich bin auf dem jan ja ok etc in der dhfs tools scripts in it top
drop shell ok leute das muss natürlich schon sein oder also gar classic classic
in der trama fs bonus notfall träger stand immer schnell
grepp qw drop shell proxime ach so die idee ist eigentlich ganz cool aber
promise also dass sie das im ort sollte sollte schon sein das ist schon enorm
wichtig ohne emojis geht ja nix
warum sollte das da rein okay ich kopiere es einfach
ok ich habe heute wir haben vibe atmen also wie war das hier wollen
etc in ram fs tools scripts auch für was sind diese fahrzeuge wollen wir fragen jetzt einfach
mal für was sind alle diese verzeichnisse und in welcher reihenfolge wird ausgeführt
gute frage das ist genau der richtige punkt alter laber halt immer chat gpt man classic
Classic Init RAMFS Tools
Chat Classic
Boote den Fasen
Also grobe Boot Reihenfolge
Init Top
Init Premount
Init Local Top
Ja dann würde ich sagen
Wir wollen
In
Local Premount
Wollen wir eine Shell droppen
direkt vor dem hauten von hut okay das machen wir local prima und
soll ich wie sollte wie sollte man dieses ding hier anlegen
Keine Ahnung. Drop Shell Punkt. Einfach nur Drop Shell heißt das Ding.
okay das die mochi hat er irgendwie nie so ganz gecheckt war ja immer und g war
das nicht so 99er ding ja normal schon aber hier brauche ich jetzt beide way ist mein
warum ist mein wim im docker so am abschreiten checkt er das netz
Okay, der checkt es wirklich nicht
Aber Cat checkt das dann
Okay, alles gut, passt, soll mir recht sein
Meinetwegen
Okay
Ähm
also ich habe keine ahnung was das hier oben macht ich lasse es jetzt einfach
mal drin
shopping zu in die trance das müssen wir eigentlich gar nicht
waren auch minus ich glaube nicht dass man exakt davor brauchen
wir warten jetzt noch bis dhcp fertig ist wie checke ich okay wie kriege ich raus
habe ich den snapshot schon gelöscht ich kann
Wie kriege ich da am besten raus, ob ich schon eine IPv4 Adresse habe?
UEFI bootet auf jeden Fall eine ganze Ecke langsamer.
Install.
Machen wir jetzt hier mal ssh.
nicht debian es ist gut
okay wie kriege ich raus ob ich schon ip habe also machen wir mal irgendwie ip-4 kann man
glaube ich machen okay ip-4 address sowas wie show oder so noch hinten dran ist das gleiche
So, grepp-v
Moment, ip
Ah, der zeigt das Loopback nicht an
Wobei, wir filtern das trotzdem
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, grepp-1, 7.0.0
Filtern wir mal raus
Wer weiß nicht, dass er das Loopback noch da anzeigt
Grepp, wir filtern den Loopback raus
Und dann greppen wir nach
Inet
Leerzeichen.
Aha.
Und wenn er das...
Okay, das heißt, weil...
Äh...
Alter, äh...
Wie...
Konnte man das einfach so machen?
U, Echo.
Eins, dann...
Uh!
Äh...
Ach nee, nee, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich will...
Weil not.
Weil not will ich haben.
Okay.
Jetzt crepten wir mal was, was es nicht gibt.
Und, okay, immer ein Sleep rein.
Sleep 1.
Okay.
Echo.
Wait for DHCP.
Hier machen wir noch ein Clear vorher rein.
Hält mir gerade ein.
Clear.
IP-Ad
geben wir auch noch vorher aus.
Dass man weiß, was Sache ist.
ATCP gibt es auch, ja.
Der bringt mir
bloß in dem Fall nichts.
Okay.
Dann kopieren wir das hier noch rein.
Äh.
waiting for dhcp so das ding muss ich aber unbedingt copy pasten
so weil das muss ich meinen docker file rein das ist hier das übrigens hier das muss auch anders
hier nicht so lange ihn hat noch nicht geklebt noch nicht da ist dann weiter dhcp okay gut
aber das mal zu ebos pxe boot das ding nennen wir drop shell ok ca mod plus x job shell und
das muss hierhin etc in der drama des tools local mount also doch feier war das hier copy
wie habe ich den kram noch mal genannt top shell top shell top shell
okay jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wieso steht im docker fall zwei mal ab update weil darum
gebakt hat vorhin keine ahnung eigentlich braucht man das nicht der
hardcore umgebacht hat mehr stiftung bagger
network
Install.
Da sind wir.
Ja, das ist ja richtig nice, Leute.
Guck mal.
Jetzt.
Okay.
Das Emoji können wir wieder rausnehmen, Leute.
Das funktioniert hier auf dem Kernelframe-Buffer nicht.
Aber das ist ja richtig nice.
Jetzt kriege ich hier ausgegeben,
was die IP-Adresse ist und alles
und habe hier eine Shell ohne dieses ganze andere Giraffe.
Ja, das ist richtig, richtig nice.
Das gefällt mir.
Jetzt machen wir noch einen.
Jetzt machen wir noch einen
finalen Test.
und zwar wir tun einfach mal so als gibt es diese vm hier nicht auf
vm directory remove
xe test beim ok so so wie wenn ich sonst normalen vor allem anlege also tag new vm custom next nix
zum installieren linux linux linux perfekt wird ständig auswählen wo sie spritsch network weil
mit nadd funktioniert es logischerweise nicht.
Zack, zack, zack, zack,
zack, zack,
zack.
Vor allem erstellt, starten.
Vor allem, wer labert,
wieder rum. Gehen wir nicht auf den Zack.
Finish Install. Erbootet.
Ich sag Install.
Ich sag S,
install stable testing sdr haus name perfekt
Rebooting.
Und fertig.
leute in 30 sekunden oder wie lange es hat ungefähr 30 sekunden würde ich sagen jetzt
genauert in 30 sekunden eine neue vm mit frisch installiertem db an allem was man braucht drauf
das ist besser als bei den cloud anbietern und lokal progress provisioning high IQ provisioning
Okay, 144. Jetzt kann ich sogar hier sagen noch, zack SSH, zack 144.
Und zwar als Debian-User.
Und es ist sogar mein SSH-Key drauf und ich kann mich per SSH drauf verbinden.
Viel besser geht's dann immer.
Und das Schöne ist, ich werde es jetzt so einrichten.
Ah ja, Moment, der installiert im Hintergrund noch Sachen.
Soll der erstmal abfertig machen.
Das Schöne ist, ich kann jetzt hier mein Skript nächtlich laufen.
Das werde ich auch machen. Ich lasse den Raspberry.
Okay, ich lasse den Raspberry Pi über Nacht mal an.
Und dann probiere ich das morgen nochmal aus.
Ist das mittlerweile fertig mit installieren?
Immer noch nicht, okay.
Der Sorgs, Grab, Up, der macht Updates im Hintergrund.
Open VM Tools installiert er im Hintergrund gerade.
Aber die Stromkosten...
Weil der Raspberry Pi im Idle auch so viel braucht.
So, jetzt ist er fertig.
es packt manchmal ein bisschen letzter zeit ab und hier unsere neue db an kiste excellent so
was ich jetzt noch machen kann ist guck mal ich habe doch hier mein install image update
skript was meine db an images und mein netboot xyz ich muss sagen für meine verhältnisse sogar
ein relativ ordentliches script das lasse ich jetzt einfach einmal nachts laufen also zack update
bmw tc kron daily
das muss eine neue datei anlegen kann ich touch
image update punkt einfach nur mit update
vertrieblichkeit so ch mod plus x image update mit update muss in so einen eigentlich vorne
um bin sh update bin sh zack und jetzt wir können das auch mal ausprobieren ob das gibt
an sich jetzt funktioniert gibt es nicht run parts oder sowas konnte man da nicht
Run Parts
Daily.
Kann ich hier sagen?
Run Parts
so tun als ob.
Daily.
Ja gut, guck.
So würde das Korn heute Nacht auch machen.
Und nachdem ich oben in mein...
Ich brech das mal ab.
Nachdem ich oben in meinem Skript...
www.html.install-image
Nachdem ich oben in meinem Skript drin stehen habe,
gehe ich immer relativ zum Pfad, wo das Skript liegt.
Und das dann auch gut.
Guck, heute Nacht läuft dann einfach sowas hier.
Der lädt sich das neueste SID-Image runter.
Packt es als LZ4-Image ein.
Das Einzige, was ich nicht machen kann, ist...
Nacht zum 2 oder so, wann Kron Daily läuft, ein neues Debian in der Zeit installieren.
Aber ich glaube, Nacht zum 2 installiere ich relativ selten neue Debions.
Oder seid ihr Nacht zum 2 Debian-Enjoyer?
Wieso das? Ja, ganz ungewöhnlich, ne?
ganz ungewöhnlich können die neuen
raspberry pi ist eigentlich poe
nachts am 22 am schnellsten weil das
netzwerk leer ist der poe hätte ich
dachte native
Aber der Pi 5 auch nicht, oder?
Chat, ich sag mal, wenn euch der Stream gefallen hat, ich bleib noch on, ja, ich sag's jetzt mal.
Wenn euch der Stream gefallen hat, das war wirklich High IQ Content.
Also, wem es gefallen hat und mehr sowas in der Richtung sehen will, jetzt einfach den Follow-Button drücken.
Oder natürlich auch den Subscribe-Button.
Dann sei der das nächste Mal wieder fresh mit am Start.
Und außerdem motiviert das, wenn es grüne Pfeile gibt.
In der Twitch-Statistik.
Sellout.
Bisschen Sellout muss immer sein.
Guckt ihr mal an, wie das bei anderen läuft.
Da ist hier schon Sellout-freie Zone eigentlich.
Aber ich kann verstehen, dass ihr mich nicht sammen wollt.
Ich würd mich auch nicht sammen.
Sag ich ganz ehrlich, ich würd mich auch nicht sammen.
Ich bin letzter Zeit viel zu selten da.
Aber wie gesagt, Leute, ich kann nicht.
Ich kann gar nicht.
Das liegt nicht, weil ich keinen Bock hab auf euch oder irgendwie Twitch an sich.
Ich hab da immer noch mit meinen Problemen zu kämpfen.
Und manchmal ist es halt so nervig, dass ich das dann nicht kann.
So.
so guck und schon sind meine debian images und mein netboot xyz iso aktiviert ja das ist ja
auch noch was neues fällt mir da gerade auf ich kann jetzt auch überall bei mir im netzwerk ob
er das jetzt mal richtig macht ich zeige euch das mal was für alle die das noch nicht kennen
kennt ihr netboot xyz chat wenn ich ich zeige es euch einfach mal ich kann jetzt nämlich darüber
überall bei mir im Netzwerk
netbootxyz booten.
netbootxyz ist eine
richtig nice Sache.
Und zwar ist das eigentlich
nur eine Skript-Sammlung aus PXE-Skripts,
die
alle möglichen Betriebssysteme anbieten.
So, jetzt boot ich mal
netbootxyz rein.
Das geht jetzt allerdings, muss man sagen, alles über das
Internet gleich, ja. Also dementsprechend
ist es bei weitem nicht so schnell wie
meine lokale Debian-Installation, da.
So, nachdem wir jetzt
jetzt erst mal timeout hat startet er dann doch netzbüro xyz hat man so viele linux installs
sind guck mal hier linux network installs das ist alles über px eboot hier guck mal
zack kann ich alles installieren open euler was auch immer vollständig centos einmal linux gibt
auch rocky gibt es auch rocky linux es rocky linux gibt's da hat man live cds also ich könnte jetzt
beispielsweise sagen okay ich wollte jetzt schon immer mal elementary os version 7 hier live booten
und dann geht das alles über netboot xyz wir machen keinen einen volt mache ich nicht web ist
so abfuck, da kannst du mich jagen
mit. Das mach ich nicht.
Arch-Install-Stream haben wir doch schon oft gemacht.
Okay, Kernel-Panic. Nice.
Sehr gut, nett,
Boot XYZ. Hat ja richtig gut
funktioniert.
Kernel-Panic.
Okay. Elementary
ist anscheinend nicht so gut, da drüber zu booten.
Booten wir mal
was anderes, okay?
Booten wir mal irgendeine Rescue-CD oder so.
Vorführeffekt.
Ich kann nichts für die Netboot XYZ-Images.
Wenn die halt sacken, dann sacken sie.
Das ist nichts, wo ich was dran ändern kann.
Nehmen wir mal irgendeine Rescue-CD oder so.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was meine Lieblings-Rescue-CD ist mittlerweile?
Ich brauche nicht oft welche.
Ich gleich dazu sagen.
Und ich rede auch nur im privaten Umfeld,
weil bei uns auf der Arbeit brauchen wir auch keine
Rescue-CD, da lockt man sich einfach aus VMware-Interface
ein.
Wenn man da
irgendwas dran machen muss.
So, ähm,
und da kann man dann theoretisch von einem Live-Linux booten,
aber das habe ich bis jetzt in den ganzen Jahren
noch nicht gebraucht. Zumindest
meine Lieblings
Live-CD
oder Rescue-CD ist tatsächlich
Linux Mint mittlerweile.
Und wisst ihr auch warum? Ich zeige es euch mal.
Starten jetzt mal Linux Mint.
LMDE
Made XFCE
starten wir jetzt.
Weil Linux Mint
Ah, ich glaube,
ich weiß, woran es liegt. Ich habe zu wenig RAM.
Leute, ich habe zu wenig RAM.
Die Kiste ist doch total klein
professioniert hier.
Ich habe zu wenig RAM. Das ist es.
Chat, deswegen kackt das ab.
das reicht für keine grafische oberfläche guck mal wir machen mal hier 44 cpu und machen
8 gig 768 zu wenig gerade wenn es aus der rem disc läuft jetzt wird es auch funktionieren
event bring mir von meinem fall nichts weil dann kannst du es mit booten also mir ist das
viel lieber wenn ich irgendwas anderes braucht netzwerk oder hat mein lokales
debian install was kein debian install ist sondern super schnelles cloud cloud image
viel besser also px hat mich im kopf heute ein bisschen bin ich auch durchdrehen aber man muss
sagen hat gut geklappt oder im großen und ganzen ich habe ja auch schon vorher ein bisschen geguckt
so live cds linux mit 21 xfc jetzt geht das mit den guten auch wenn man genug ram hat
Guck und schon funzt.
Kaum hat man genug RAM.
Warum brauchen die jetzt so lange?
Was macht der da?
Ah!
Der!
der lädt sich jetzt erst mal das mit image runter du kram ja ich habe noch 64 im rechner
habe das ding aber auch 2022 wisst ihr was ich richtig krass finde ich habe mir diesen rechner
hier gekauft dezember 2022 meint es war damals besser ging es nicht 13.900 k ohne 40 90 mir
muss ich mal überlegen das ding ist jetzt sagen wir mal drei jahre alt okay auf die zwei monate
scheißen wir mal drei jahre alt und drei also sagen wir über drei jahre alt okay etwas über
drei jahre alt und der rechner war damals ziemlich high end und ist es immer noch drei jahre über
knapp über drei jahre später eine 40 90 und 13.000 heute immer noch extrem gut drei jahre später
früher konnte eineinhalb jahren rechner wegschmeißen
schon krass oder
wahrscheinlich kriege ich einen rechner wenn ich mal dran verkaufen würde
mit
also ich bilde mir einen mind hat eigentlich feuerwehrtools
aber markt jetzt anscheinend nicht so wissen wisst ihr was ich bei linux mit enorm sehr
nice finde das ist dass die zfz drauf haben da kannst du standardmäßig ohne was nachzudenken
kannst du zfz sachen die bank mit als live system das finde ich cool und es ist ganz
normales debian drunter das heißt du kannst ja auch sachen nach installieren
also als live image muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich brauche keine extra rescue cds
oder irgendwie so ein blödsinn mehr
einfach linux mint und gutes natürlich nur wenn man ins internet kommt ja wenn
man nicht ins internet kommt und was komplett das braucht mit rescue tools und
zeug okay aber dann ist auch mit netboot xyz nicht dann musst du auch das lokale
ISO mitnehmen.
Power of Bam.
Open VM Directory.
Zack, zack. Weg damit.
Weg damit.
Und direkt
recyceln.
Was macht eigentlich meine Festplattenbelegung
so? Okay.
Die Hälfte von meiner 4TB
SSD ist schon wieder voll.
Kaum hat man den
Speicher, benutzt man ihn auch.
Ja, ja, ja, wenn es AirGap-Systeme sind,
dann würde ich sowas auch benutzen, wie Ventoy zum
Booten mit einem USB-Stick.
Aber für sowas
hier ist das top. Für daheim ist das richtig
nice.
Ja.
So, Chat.
Jetzt gehe ich wieder was futtern.
Im Prinzip
wurden heute meine Streams ja nur vom Essen
unterbrochen, ne? Aufwachen-Stream?
Fertig? Mittagessen? Wieder on?
Nachmittagstream?
Essen? Jetzt wieder off?
Ne, es gab keine Nudeln mit Lachs.
Es gab heute Nudeln mit Hähnchen.
Aber jetzt gehe ich erstmal was essen, Leute.
So.
Also.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
heute extremer 5 at iiq content wir hören uns chat bis zum nächsten mal
macht's gut